foreign
foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will be having an Excel fill course but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without any
further Ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's discussion
first we will get started with some
basics of Microsoft Excel then we will
understand the sort and filter functions
in Excel followed by that we will dive
deep into the functions available in
Microsoft Excel then we will move ahead
by learning conditional formatting data
validation in Excel then we will
understand the pivot tables and charts
provided by Microsoft Excel then we will
start the data analysis in Excel once we
are done with data analytics we will
understand the macros and visual basics
in Microsoft Excel and followed by that
we will try to create Excel dashboards
using the analytics what we performed on
the previous topics and finally to help
you grab that dream job in data
analytics we will also help you with
some most frequently Asked interview
questions based on Excel I hope I made
myself clear with the agenda now let's
get started with the first topic that is
Microsoft Excel basics
now let's look at the scenario here so
one day in a startup
One Professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague response
well we can make use of Microsoft Excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to their business needs
now
the colleague response well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question says let's go ahead with
Excel and let's train our employees in
Excel
and the suggestion is welcomed which
would make the job easier for them and
they would basically decide on using
Excel so they decide on taking a
training right away and basically
starting to learn Excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use Excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so Excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in Excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data and Excel also allows
you to beautify your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and Analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
Excel also provides good security for
your data Excel files have the feature
of password protection this way your
information can be safe
now when we talk about what is Excel and
how it can be used so Excel or you might
have heard a spreadsheet can be
basically used for lot of different
tasks than just storing the information
in so-called tabular format
now Microsoft Excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in Excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a small tour to understand how to
work with Excel now to do that what we
can do is we can type in in our search
say for example Excel and just select
your Excel app which is installed and
here you see you have lot of options
which says take it over drop down list
get started with formulas make your
pivot table going forward with pie
charts and much more so we can click on
this one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to Excel and if you
have always wanted to be better at Excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on Create and that takes us
to the store window now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically talks about 10 different steps
in which we can learn Excel and using
the spreadsheet app so there are more
than 11 sheets which we see here at the
bottom end and each one gives us a
simple example which we can work on so
for example if I click on ADD now that
takes me to this page which says how do
we add numbers now you might be provided
data which we can upload by loading a
file from our machine or getting data
from a web Source or even connecting to
a database so there are various options
which we will see in some time so here
we have an option which is called Data
you can click on this one and this
basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from SQL
Server from analysis services from odata
data feed you can get in from XML from
data connection Wizard or also from
Microsoft query you can be running in
different queries here which shows up in
the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections for this particular workbook
which we do not have as of now but we
can create them but let's look at simple
examples now you can follow these
instructions here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add the data so for example I could just
do a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say I would be interested in
totaling the amount
from
column D and I would select for example
D4 so I could be doing this and then I
could say D4
onwards till d 7 so that's the data
which I'm interested in you can close
your parenthesis and hit enter and that
gives you the total there is also a
shortcut for this which you can always
do is we can first delete this and you
can just place your cursor here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime expand or basically
collapse so I will basically select this
which says this function needs two
numbers which is number one and number
two and then you can hit on enter and
that gives you the total so similarly we
can be getting in the data here by
selecting all the fields so here it also
says that you can use a shortcut now
what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50 by selecting the yellow
cell here and then giving a condition
such as so I can basically use something
like sum if and then open a parenthesis
I can select I would be interested in
this row and then I can even drag and
drop
till here so that tells me the 11 to the
15 you can then put in a comma here and
you can give your condition say for
example we would say I would be
interested in numbers only above 50 and
we can select this
close your codes and then just close
your paranthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here I could select this now
there is also an option I can click on
home and I can go for something like
Auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and I can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then I can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
summer if formula here but add amounts
that are less than 100 and the result
should be 160. so what we can do is we
can basically select all the numbers
which are lesser than 100 so the way we
did earlier here there it can be always
a shortcut so you can always for example
if you would want to avoid typing in the
formula you can always copy it from here
and then just hit on enter so you are
back into this cell and then I can
basically go here and paste the number
and then as per the requirement we are
required to select anything which is
lesser than 100 so what I could do is I
could select here I could say let's say
G and then I can change this value to
g15 and that's one more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed so I
can hit on enter and I can check what is
the result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so I will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your cells within your Excel sheet
now here we have an option which says
100 now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column C4 to D4 so if I click on this
one I can check that this is row number
four which shows up here and I also know
this is column C I also have D so this
equals is basically giving me a sum of
C4 to D4 now what we can do is we can
always place our cursor here at the
right corner and then we can just drag
and drop and this basically gives me a
total of all the numbers for all
different rows so this is one shortcut
which we can do to get the total Excel
will automatically give the totals which
we call as filling down now what we can
do is in the same way if we would want
to get the totals here we can first
check what is this 200 and this tells me
this C11 to c14 total so it is totaling
the rows from C11 so column C and 11th
row till 14th row and that's the sum now
what I can also do is I can similarly
like above we can do a filling right
which basically means bringing your
cursor here and then just dragging and
dropping it all the way where you would
need the totals and this basically gives
me the total there is one more quick way
to check if this is right so the easiest
option would be to select this cell now
what I can also do is I can just select
all of these fields by just highlighting
and selecting all the fields once it is
selected press on Ctrl R and that gives
you the total now if we would be doing
this stop down then I could select all
these rows for this particular column
and then I could do a control D so
that's your filling down and this one
was failing right so this is an easier
option of doing a fill when you would
want to have the formula applied to
every row as it occurs in the first row
or the last row we could test this by
for example selecting these fields I
could delete them and I have here which
says 130 I could just place my cursor
here and I could drag it all the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from top down so
this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email IDs and
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now I see that there
is a last name Smith filled up here
first name is empty so what I can also
do is I can just type in say Nancy here
now that's the first name I can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say Nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in Andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name what
we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now I can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking Ctrl Z and that's basically
gone what I can also do is I can select
a particular field and then I can go
into home option and under home you have
an option here which says fill so you
can select this and then you can do a
Flash Fill which is what we are doing
here so click on Flash Fill and that
automatically fills up the values so in
this way you can work within your
spreadsheet and you can be filling up
the values where a delimiter by default
is understood and we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter and there is again a smarter
way of splitting your data so you can
always scroll down here and that says
splitting a column based on delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and these values in each row are
separated by comma so
select this your data is already
selected text to columns delimited comma
selected and now click on next so it
basically says what is the destination
let's select this one
and I can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
GitHub preview now I can basically
select this one I can say finished and
say okay and now if you see our data has
been placed in in the columns
appropriately so this is how you can
split your data based on a delimiter and
then organize your data in a better way
now there are some Advanced options
which we can learn later but this
basically tells about using a formula so
this is something if say if we have some
name in one cell and if you would want
to split it into first name your helper
column your middle name last name so
that can also be done using formulas and
this basically tells how would you
extract characters from your left cell
and how would you place them in your
right cell so you can try this activity
which is a little more of advanced
option the benefit is that you can
always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation using your formulas if
your original data gets updated then the
split data will also get updated and
that's the benefit of using formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your X and Y axis or as I would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and I would say two rows now I
can select all of these and then I can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt V that's a
shortcut what you can also do is once
you have selected all your Fields you
can just copy them so just do a Ctrl C
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
OK and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as a mount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed in this particular
format now there is another way of doing
that and again that's using your
formulas so what you can do is you can
transpose with a formula also and that
basically works when you have similar
kind of data so this has six columns and
basically two rows so you can basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier we were doing a copy but now
what we would want to do is we would
want to just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c33 c34 and it
starts with c and ends in with your H
column so what we can do is we know that
we have six columns and two rows so
transposing that would actually give me
two columns and six rows so what we can
do is we can select two columns and six
rows in our Excel sheet I can then
basically start typing in the message or
I can just go to the address bar and
here I can say
transpose
let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data and now
I can just do a control shift and enter
and now if you see all the values have
been populated now you can just place
your cursor in one of the cells but if
you see the address bar the formula
Remains the Same this is because this is
an array formula so we can read more
about an array formula here it's
basically something which performs
calculations and on more than one cell
in an array and in the example here the
array is the original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing the horizontal orientation to
the vertical orientation so this is a
very simple way in which you can
basically use the excel's capability to
transpose your data and convert your
rows into to columns and columns into
rows apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting the data or basically
splitting your data transposing your
data one of the other requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how Excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so let's check that
so if we're going to sort and filter and
say this is the data I have say for
example I would want to sort the values
in the department column alphabetically
so what I can do is I can select
Department column and I'm already in the
Home tab I can straight away go here
which says sort and filter here I can
then say sort A to Z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column and once once I do
this you would see the data has been
sorted but it's not just this data we
can just do a control Z and check what
are the values we have so here we have
meet which is beef and 90
000 hundred ten thousand the values then
you have Bakery which should ideally be
the first row if we sort it in an
alphabetical order which goes with
Bakery as desserts you have the values
so we can check this again so select
department and then just do a sort and
filter and let's say sort A to Z and if
you see the data has changed but it's
not just in changing your First Column
but then it has taken care of all the
data however the data has been sorted
based on the department column so you
have Bakery which aligns with deserts
which has the values and now we we have
all the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do is we can sort
December's amounts from largest to
smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the December
column let's say 20 000 and then what I
can do is I can go into sort filter and
then I can say sort largest to smallest
so if you see Bakery breads is the row
which has the smallest data or maybe you
have Delhi sandwiches so that one looks
also smaller so let's do a larger to
smallest and if I do this you would see
the values have been shifted now so it
is no more based on the department
column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the December
column and you see Bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes based on
the values these are all string values
or words so it sorts alphabetically if
you have numbers might be you can give
some values and you can sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select if you would
want to select the data so I could do a
custom sort and then I could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the Sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is
its cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that now if you scroll down that also
shows how you can sort by date or a
color so for example if you would want
to sort based on the expense date so
there are different options so what I
can do is I can select this date field I
can just do a right click I can go into
sort and then I can choose I would want
to sort oldest to newest so since I
selected the date field it basically has
sorted all the data and it has taken the
expense State into consideration now
there are these filters which you see on
the row headings we could have also used
those so I could have selected this and
that basically says or mentions which
are the dates I would be interested in
looking at I also have sort by color
here I can do a sort oldest or newest or
newest to oldest so I could also use
these filters which have been applied
here now we have the data which is in
color so if I would want to basically
select the color columns or color cells
I could select this I can basically do a
right click here and when I go into sort
I could choose put selected color or
cell color on the top and that basically
will make sure that my data is sorted
and it has also sorted that in a
descending order so in this way you can
sort or or basically filter your data
what we can also do is we can add
filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can basically
select the filter which has been applied
here now how does the filter come in
there so if I would select a particular
row I could select a particular row and
then I could decide if I would want to
just add a filter to this one and that's
how the filter has come in so we have
the filter what we can do is we can
basically click on this drop down and
then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these so we can
basically choose above average so I
could select this and then basically it
shows me the values we could also delete
the filter by clicking on this one and
we could say well I'm not interested in
this filter anymore
so I could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values or I could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food I can go in here I can go
into number filters and then I could say
well I'm interested in values which are
below average above average might be
greater than and then I can choose what
is the value so for example if we say
I'm interested in food which is greater
than 25 dollars I could give a value
here I could say okay and now I have
applied the filter similarly you can
select this and then you can just clear
your filter and your data is back so
remember no data is lost it is just
hidden or basically based on the filter
not shown so that's good enough for us
and in this way you can sort and filter
the data so for more details obviously
in all the sheets you have the links
which point to more information on the
web and you can always refer to these so
this is simple way in which you can sort
and filter any amount of data which has
been stored within your Excel within a
particular sheet now that we have
learned about add fill split transpose
sorting and filtering it will also be
good to learn how to work with tables or
basically converting your data into a
tabular format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in five columns and N
number of rows so I can basically select
this data and then what I can do is I
can insert choose the table option and
then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that I'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use and this is basically my
table which is a collection of cells
which has some special features so we
can easily add rows to this table we can
add columns to this table and we can
even do some calculations so for example
here I can click on this one I can
basically enter some field and then I
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example I
would say chocolates
I could give some value here size 25
000 might be 35
000 and then basically I can given some
values here now what you can also do is
you can continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created columns for my
next months wherein I can feed in the
data so this is a similar way wherein
you can keep adding more rows and
columns to your data if that has been
converted in a tabular format now let me
just do a control Z that basically
deletes the columns again Ctrl Z deletes
the last row which we added and I can
stop here or I can even remove my values
by doing multiple control Z and removing
my rows so this is how I converted my
data into a table and then I can easily
work on this what I can also do is I can
do some calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals and that basically says what is
this doing so it says it is calculating
the sum of the last three months and if
that's what you would want to do just
hit on enter and it has automatically
calculated the totals for all your rows
for these three columns so the sum
formula is getting filled up now I can
select any particular cell and I can
look in my address bar so it has already
given me the formula where it has
started calculating the sum from the
October column till the December column
and has given me the calculated values
of the columns what we can also do is we
can get total rows in the table now
that's a simpler option so what we can
do is we can select any l in this
particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
I can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here and if you would want the
average then we could select this and
from the drop down I can select what I'm
interested in so for example I would
want the average values and not the
total I could just select this and that
gives me the average of these values so
we can always do simpler computations
here by converting our data into table
format let's learn about one more
efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here now say for example
you have this data which has the values
in the food column and department is
empty and say for example you would want
to enter the values in Department
however you would want to select the
department should either have produce or
meet and bakery and these are the only
three options which should be available
for any user to fill in the values how
do we do that so we can basically create
a table by pressing Ctrl D so what I can
do is under my department
here I can select one of the cells and
then I can do a control T that basically
converts this into a table I can say
okay and my table is created now what I
can do is once this part is done
we can select all the blank Fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable now under your data tab you
can go in and select data validation and
this has an option called Data
validation click on this which basically
says allow any value so here I will
select I would want to give a list of
values and then I can type in my values
here which I can say produce
say for example meet and then say Bakery
now these are the values so we can click
on okay
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to Apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so I can go into every cell and
then I can basically choose what is the
department which handles this and then
basically I can select one of these from
the drop down so this is an easier
option of creating your drop down and
then feeding in the values from the set
of values which you have defined here on
the right so this is a simple example of
using your drop downs working with your
tables working with your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use Excel for more than one use
case using its inbuilt features to
easily work with your data let's see how
we can import data or bring in data into
our Excel from your local machine or
from an external web source so what we
can do is we can open up a blank Excel
sheet and say for example you have been
provided a text file or a CSV file and
you would want to import that data into
your Excel sheet that can be easily done
so right now I've opened an
Excel sheet now I can click on data and
here I have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources so or you can click on
connections if you have already created
some so we can click on from other
sources so this is one option where you
can connect to your different data
sources and you can get the data from
one of these what we can also do is I
can click on connections now it says
there is none I can click on ADD it says
well show the connections where
connection files or Network
connection files on this computer so I
can say let's get some files from this
computer now if that does not show up
something so say browse for more and
that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where I have some data sets I'll
click in here and this is basically a
folder where I have some data sets now
let me select this particular file and I
know it is a CSV file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a DOT CSV file which is what we
are interested in so I'll take this file
I'll say open now this basically shows
me the text import wizard option which
says is the file delimited I'll say yes
click on next so I will select comma as
my delimiter I can say text qualifier is
none now this is my data so my data
preview is already showing me the data
is what is the data in the CSV file you
can click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is General
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so I'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here so we basically have this and now I
can click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on OK and now this
data is automatically inserted in my
Excel file I can basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what I
can do is I can go into my GitHub and
let's say I would be interested in this
CSV file so I can select this and this
is my GitHub path a path on web so I can
click on draw and that basically gives
me the raw path where this particular
file is now you can select this copy
this particular path and here you can
come back to your Excel sheet we would
be interested in getting the data from
web might be from a text file where we
will have to specify the delimiters or
let's go to web and here I can given the
web path from where I would be
interested in getting the file let's
give the GitHub path which is publicly
available and then click on import now
once you click on import it tells me
that two Fields data and value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on OK and now you have the data
coming in but then this basically shows
me in one particular field so what we
can also do is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here and
that's my data so we can then basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next we
can select comma and let the text
qualifier be codes
it shows me data preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column click
on finish and now your data has been
split and you have the data which you
have imported from web so this is the
data which is coming in from web this is
the data which came in from my local
machine and similarly we can even create
connection with an existing database so
I can basically click on connections if
I would want to do that so I have an
option called connection here and it
says where the selected connections are
used I can basically click on ADD I can
basically choose if I would want to get
the files from Network or from computer
like we did earlier
I can click on browse for more which
should show me different other options
to create connections say you would want
to create a new SQL Server Connection
you can connect to a new data source
coming in from different place you could
basically choose what kind of connection
you would you want so these are all the
different options which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example if I have some
database and say for example access
database
I can see if there are some files with
that particular database and I can
import it so similarly we can also uh
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mySQL database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your Hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your Excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your Excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in Excel and
let's Implement our knowledge by working
on this particular data which is coming
in from housing data set now here if we
see some fields we have agent date
listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been sorted
in newest to oldest order of date listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what I can do is I can
just click on data listed and then I can
either go in here I can select sort I
can get into custom sort and then I can
choose the column based on which I would
want to sort the data so I would look
for the newest data to the oldest data
that means that would be in a descending
order of dates or you could say the
oldest state or the earliest month will
be towards the lower side of your sheet
so here we can select date listed now I
can say let it sort based on Cell values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this I can say OK and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in the state
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example I
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area and descending order of
agent name how do we do that so let's
look into this so this is here I already
have the result here and how did I get
this so I'm looking for ascending order
of area and descending order of agent
name so we can start with any particular
column that does not matter so for
example if I look into this Excel sheet
I have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order so we
could either do a sort and then go for
descending sort Z to A we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or I could just say
sort Z to A and then it has arranged the
data based on the agent column being in
descending order now I can go into area
and then I can again do a sort and I
wanted my area column to be used for
sorting the data and ascending to
descending and that basically not only
changes the order of this particular
column but for my complete data so let's
do that and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here and the
area values which we see and this is how
you get your result so I'll just do a
control Z and again and I'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing at similarly
we can answer other questions for
example sort the data according to the
following order of area that is we are
saying counties
Central and then your county so we can
basically choose in which particular way
we would want to do it so it is County
Central and then again County so if I
look into my G3 so here I basically have
my data which is having some South
County then you have your Central and
then you have your North County so we
would want to sort the data to solar
problem which is according to the
following order so first we go for area
then we go for South County Central and
North County so what we can do is we can
basically have area field selected and I
would want to sort this particular data
so I have South County Central and North
County so I can basically go for custom
sort
and then I can choose which is the value
or column which I'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like cell
values well you can also try to explore
conditional formatting icon if this is
what you would want to use or we can
basically go for just cell values and
here we can say if I would be interested
in first getting my values for South
County so for example I can say custom
list and then I can basically given the
new list here so I can say s
Dot County
and then I would want Central and then I
would want North County
so let's select this
as it exists we can basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with Kelly you have in the 12th
row something like Lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data so that's one more simpler
task what we have done where we have
sorted the data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
South County then we wanted Central data
and then we wanted North County so this
is how you can do it now let's look into
one more problem so it says find all the
houses in the central area and we would
want to basically apply a regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this and here we have the
data so the problem statement is we
would want to find all the houses in
Central Area now how do we do that we
can do a sorting but we would want to
use the filter which you see here is
implemented so how do you do it so you
can select this area and say for example
I would want to apply filter I can just
go in here and I can say let's get a
filter on my first row and now I have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the Central Area houses
let's go in here it says all these
fields are selected that means it shows
everything wherein your area has all
these values let's unselect this and
then I will only be interested in the
central so let's say okay and then say
okay so now you see that the area filter
has been applied and we are looking at
the central column so what we have done
is we have applied a simple filter and
we are looking at our data at any point
of time if you do not want the filter
then what I can do is I can select this
and I can say well I'm interested in all
the data so I could do this or you can
clear the filters from area and you get
your data back so that's in one way you
can filter out your data so let's look
at an example of sort and filter where
we might have to filter the data based
on two columns or multiple columns with
different kind of values where it could
be and and or condition now say for
example this is the data I have and this
is the question which we need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region with pool and South
County without pool now if it was a
simple filter based on one cell I could
have just selected my header row I could
have then applied the filter
and once I have the filter I can look in
area where I have three regions so I'm
only interested in Central and South
County so I can get rid of North County
and that's fine but then we have two
different conditions here so we need the
data in central region to have the value
for pool being true
and for South County the value has to be
without pool now how do we do that so
what we can do is we can first create a
copy of these headers here so let me do
that now the area has to be South County
so basically I can either just select
this and I can choose this value
and then I can select this and then I
can choose Central so that's the
criteria which I have and the pool value
has to be so central region should be
with pool so then this one
basically has to be true
and this one has to be basically false
so south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now to get my result we
can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is M column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called Advanced and here
what I can do is I can say I would want
to filter the list in the place but
that's not what I would want to do so
I'll say copy to another location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me that this is the data so A1 to J 126
so a to J column selected and all the
rows
criteria range is basically based on
what I have given here so that is m
from 1
to V which is 3
so I'm selecting these columns and then
I am saying all the way whatever
criteria I have given and copy 2 I am
saying M8
to V8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay and now I have my data
which has been filtered and I have my
area which is South County that is
without Pool Central with pool again
South County without pool and then if
you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either replacing
the existing content or in the same
sheet in different set of columns and
rows you can have your result let's look
at one more example of filtering where
you are trying to filter the data data
based on a and condition condition being
met in two different columns and then
you would want to filter out the data
for only specific columns so the
situation is the agents with a house in
North County that should be County area
having two and a single type family so
we are talking about two bedrooms and we
would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that if
we would want to only populate these
columns which is Agent area bedroom and
type now what you can do is as I
explained earlier that you can get your
result in the same sheet in a different
location so here I have created these
headers which says agent area bedrooms
and type now this is basically a copy of
all the columns what we have here agent
data listed area list Place bedrooms
bath square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
Advanced criteria to filter the data so
the conditions which need to be met is
we need to look at North County so for
example here in area I can basically go
ahead and select one of the values North
County now the criteria is having two
bedrooms only so let's say bedrooms and
let's say the value should be 2
and then basically I am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type I
can give the criteria single type so
this is my and condition so we are
saying North County area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if I select this this one tells me
that this is m one row onwards till V
2 so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this so let's go
ahead and then go for data filter
Advanced and here in advanced it says
filter the list in place now that's not
what we would want to do so I'll say
copy to another location this basically
selects the list range so which is
telling me A1
2 J 126 so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on M1 V2 which we have given
here and copy to I would say for example
from M7
2
P 7 now this is the area where I would
this is the place where I want the
result let's say okay and now I get my
data which is based on the question
which has been asked that you would want
the agents with a house in North County
area having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way you can basically
do Advanced filtering get your data and
get it stored in the sheet anywhere at a
different location well I could have
also done filtering in place and that
would have replaced the data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some Advanced filtering we can
also use Excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say using some numerical
filters now here say for example the
problem statement is that you would want
to display all the houses whose list
price is between
45
000 to 600 000 or say for example we
would want to filter out the data to
something else say for example let's say
I have I would want to filter out the
data between 300
000 and 400 000 so we can basically
update this say for example I am saying
I am interested in 300
000
to
400. 1000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways or there are two easier
ways to do it one is I would want to
look at the list price so I can select
this I can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so I
could basically select this I could say
I am looking for Value which is greater
than or equal to three hundred thousand
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if I just do this I have applied
my filter and I have my data which is
filtered based on my criteria right so
that's one easier way of doing it or let
me do a control Z
now
let the filter be there which you can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between
my
this set of columns which I have one two
three four and then you have 7 and 10
columns and if you see here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where I can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
or condition would lie in a different
line now here I can give this value so I
am looking for listed price being
between 300 000 so I am saying it should
be greater than or equal to 300
000 and then I can say less than or
equal to 400
000 now that's my criteria and then I
need my result here which is in M 7 so
what I can do is once I have given my
criteria which I'll be using to filter I
can get into Data I can get into
advanced and then I can say copy to
another location so it is selecting my
A1 to J 126 criteria range is based on
M1 to
W2 and then I would want my result from
this particular column so let's say okay
and now you have your data filtered out
in a different location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
Excel where we would have an and and an
or condition so say for example this is
the data given to you and the question
is that you would want to find all the
houses in North County again that's a
spelling mistake but then they are North
County area with a list price greater
than 300 000 and having three or four
bedrooms so the bedroom has conditional
so it has R 3 and 4 and then basically
you have list price which is greater
than three hundred thousand now I could
have obviously selected The Columns and
then basically gone for a filter so I
can just do a filtering here and then
I'm looking for list price being greater
than 300 000 so which we can always give
a number filter and I can say greater
than and then I can say greater than or
equal so I can say greater than and then
I can give 3030 300 000 and that's
basically the filter which we would want
and here I would want to select the
bedrooms which should be just either
three or four so if for example here I
go in here and I unselect this and then
I say 3 and 4 right so I am getting my
data which is greater than 300 000 and
it should have the bettering values
which will be either 3 or 4 selected now
that's one way of doing it let's do a
control Z and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
hear
give the criteria
so for example I have my list price now
this is what I would want as a condition
so let's say greater than
three hundred thousand
300 000 and bedrooms should be three
and then I can say greater than 300 000
and then I can say 4 so this one
basically gives me a situation where
your list price has to be greater than
300 000 and bedroom should be either
three or four so we have given our
filtering criteria now to get the result
what we can do is we can go into Data we
can go into advanced and we can say copy
to another location so our list range is
selected which is columns a to J row
number 1 to 126 your criteria range is
given in M1 to V3 where we have
specified and we are saying the result
would be in M 7 to V7 so if I do this
now I have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier and here the bedroom
values are three or four and basically
the list price is greater than 300 000.
so this is a simpler way in which you
can create your filters and all this
Advanced filtering what we are seeing it
it will be saved with your sheet you can
always go back and change this value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected
now that we have looked into some
operations which we can perform in Excel
using filter or sorting the data
creating your tables let's also quickly
look at functions and formulas which can
be used for doing some easy calculations
or computations now Excel can be used in
different kind of data analysis so for
example you have different inbuilt
functions which can be used and we can
always check for a particular function
so for example if I had if I wanted to
look at a particular function I could
just type in here something for example
is and then it shows me all the possible
functions and you can always have a look
at the detail of the function for
example you have is even which will
return true if the number is even if we
would say is logical so I I could search
for is logical and that tells me whether
a value is logical value true or false
and returns your value true and false
now we can obviously
say subtotal so you can search for any
of these useful functions and that tells
me what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal in a list or a
database
you have many other such functions such
as integer sum average you may be
interested in working on truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root basically
getting a count or getting a max value
you can look for any particular
functions within your Excel sheet now
you also have other functions such as
now or time for example let's look at
Now function so I can search for
now
and here it is so this is Returns the
current date and time formatted as a
date and time so this is the function
which we would want to use and if I just
give the function it tells me what is
the current time let's first look at the
description of time here so say for
example I would want time it says
converts hours minutes and seconds given
as numbers to an Excel serial number
formatted with a time format so for
example if I would say two hours and
then 30 minutes and 30 seconds and if I
do this it has basically converted this
into your time format so you can always
use different inbuilt functions for your
work now we will also look at some
Advanced functions like sumf or some ifs
you have countif and countifs and you
can be working on various
functionalities of excel to easily help
you in doing some calculations
computations working with your data
working with your different cell values
so let's look at some example of using
functions like sum or sum if so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data now I have already applied a
filter which can allow me to filter out
the data so it says find the total units
that were sold in the east region now we
know that in region we have east
and
I have multiple regions I could
basically be saying unselect all and
select only East
and say okay and that basically gives me
the units which were sold and if I place
my cursor here and then if I did a auto
sum so it would basically give me
the function which is being used so
something like subtotal and it is
basically working on your rows which is
E2 to e44
and here we can just do this so that
gives me the total but this is this is
fine you could do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sumif to do that so
here I am seeing this is the subtotal
where I am looking at the values and
basically what I have done is I have
filtered out the region
and then basically I am getting a count
but this does not give me clearly how a
sum was calculated from all the values
which were listed what we can also do is
let's do a control Z and let's get it
back so now we have our data and we
would want to get the total units that
were sold in the east region so what I
can do is I can start typing in my
formula and for that I'll use an inbuilt
function so for example I would be
interested in going for sumif now it
says sum if adds the cells specified by
a given condition or criteria when you
talk about some ifs this is when you
could give set of conditions or multiple
criteria so let's look at some if let's
do this now obviously this gives me an
error because the formula
is not right so we have to basically
come in here and let's start with sum if
now when I say sum if it shows me there
is a function with sum if which we would
want to use and here once I open up the
bracket it tells me okay what is the
range of data which you are interested
in so I am interested in all the units
that were sold in the east region so we
are interested in the region
which is here so I can basically be
selecting this and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header value so let's
say B2 and then we can go all the way to
the end so we can basically select this
way
that's the data we have select this and
hit enter so now here it has selected B2
to B4 but we need to basically now give
the criteria so the criteria is either a
value or you can point it to a cell
which has that particular value so as
per our problem statement we are looking
for the units which are sold in east
region so I can select the value East
here and then my sumif needs the range
on which you want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units so that's basically this column e
column so I can basically type in
instead of selecting so I can say e and
I'm interested in e 2 2 e 44 so that
basically selects the area or all the
values and now let's do this so that
basically gives me the sum is 691 right
now this is the criteria where I have
pointed it to a cell and whatever value
that cell has well I could have done
something like this so I could have
selected East giving the value and then
doing it it still does the same thing
and in this way you have more clarity
that you are using sumif you are
filtering the data so you have given the
rows you are given the criteria and then
you have given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values now similarly if the question was
what was the total revenue generated
from binder now we would want to find
out what is the total revenue generated
from binders that means my filtering
criteria will be binder
and then I want to find out the total
revenue generated so we have the revenue
generated field also here and we have we
don't have any region to be filtered we
are just looking for binder so let's
again start doing the same thing so we
can go for some if we can open the
bracket now it needs the range so we are
interested in revenue generated now
that's the summation we want and we
would want to
get the range of data so here we can
basically select
uh d
2
D 44
so that's the data selected now I would
filtering criteria so let's say binder
and then we need to give the range on
which the sum needs to be calculated so
that's my Revenue column so that's G so
I can say G to to G 44 and that
basically selects the column and then
you get your sum so it tells me what is
the total revenue generated from binder
now I could be doing this for other
things also so say for example if you
would want to filter out something else
you could basically just drag and drop
here and then I could come here and
change this to say instead of binder I
would be interested in say
pencil
if that's the criteria you are
interested in remember to change this so
that you take all the values
and here we will change
it to select the relevant rows and then
this is the data I'm getting so I know
that this is the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from binder now this is a
simple use case where we are using some
if what if we would want to use some IFS
so sum ifs let's have a look at how we
get to some ifs so sumif says where you
would want to work on
doing some calculation but then you
would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this so here what I can
do is let's work on this problem
statement which says what is the total
revenue generated from central region
where the item is a pencil so that's
something which I would want to check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the order in which
things have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total revenue
generated from central region so we need
the total revenue generated we know
there is a revenue column we are
interested in getting the total revenue
generated
we are saying the filtering criteria is
central region and we say in that we
would be interested only in the item if
it is pencil how do I do it so I can use
sumifs where you can pass in multiple
criteria so let's start with some IFS
and when I start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range then it gives one
criteria and you can give in any number
of criterias so for example we are
interested in total revenue generated
now that's my G column so let's follow
in the same order so let's say G
2
so that's my first value and then I know
there are 44 rows here so I can say G 44
and you can obviously check if that has
selected all the rows now that's my
total revenue generated so I would want
the total revenue generated so I'm
saying setting this some range
then I need to give the criteria range
so it says from central region so
central region comes into column two
that's B so let's say b 2 to B 44 so
that's my criteria range then you have
to give your criteria but we need to
filter out the region being Central so
let's select this now either I could
point to a value in the cell or I can
just give the exact value here
we can also give a
wild card or matching pattern so that
also works now this one is fine we are
now also interested in finding the total
revenue generated when the region is
Central and the item is pencil how do we
do that so for
item we know the columns the column is
D2 so let's select d 2 2 D 44 so that
basically selects all the rows in the D
column and we need to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then just given our value so let's
say pencil and then let's close your
bracket and that basically gives you the
result
so we need to just follow the order of
our question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are selecting all the rows
then it says from the central region so
we need to select the region column and
give the filtering criteria Central or
point to a cell which contains that
value and then it says we would be
interested only in item being pencil so
then you select the column which has all
the items and provide you a filtering
criteria that is pencil so that's your
easy calculation of using some if which
we compare with sum if here so sum if
here was just having
your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range in some ifs we are giving
multiple condition now same thing can be
done here it says how many units were
sold by sales representative Johns or
Jones where the cost of each item was
greater than 4. so how many units were
sold by sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your e column
so let's start with that so let's say
some ifs I would be interested in E
column
and let's give the range so it says sum
range so those are the number of units
on which we would want to find the sum
then it says you need to give the
criteria range so we say sales
representative where the name is
Jones so sales representative is in
sales rep column C so let's say C2 to
c44
now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say Jones
is the sales representative where we are
interested about whom we are interested
in and then we the question says where
the cost of each item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in you have unit cost
so that's what we are interested in so
that would be f
and then say F2 to f44
and then you need to give your cost so
it says where each item is greater than
4
so let's select this
and let's
do this so this tells me 3 0 1. now
similarly let's answer our third
question which is how many units did
Jones sell excluding
pencil item so we would want to find out
what was the total number of units units
that were sold
and that units or that should not
include the pencil item how do we start
doing this so let's start with some IFS
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum range so we are
interested in the number of units so
let's basically go in and select our
number of units which were sold so
that's your column e so I can say E2 to
e44 that's where I would want to perform
this sum now I am saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
zones so let's see let's select the
columns
C and then give
the range
after that we need to give our giving
filtering criteria which is zones and
then we are interested in the items but
excluding pencil so items is in column D
so let's say d to d44 and then we have
to give
our criteria so we can say well that
should exclude pencil
so I can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says that these are the number of
units which the sales representative
whose name is Jones had sold and that
does not include pencil as an item let's
also look at an example of using countif
or countifs now both of these can be
very useful when you would want to
calculate certain values so for example
if I would want to work on count if
let's try solving this problem now
remember you can answer these questions
using filters and that can be an easier
way but then sometimes you may want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more
dynamic in nature and that will
basically depend on the values in the
columns or rows so for example if I have
find the total number of times Gill has
made a sale now if I look at my data
here it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value in
the sale and it says sales has greater
than 3 so for example Jones you have
sales greater than three or you have
Jardine which is sales greater than 3
and so on so what we are interested in
is doing a quick count and finding out
the total number of times Gill has made
a sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if function and if I go into
countif it says counts the number of
cells within a range that meet the given
condition now what's our condition our
condition is Gill and we would want to
find out how many times the name say
Gill appears or kill has made a sale now
I could just say count if and then open
up a bracket I need to give a range so
let's say we are interested in looking
at the range so let's say we will choose
sales rep so I can say C and then I can
say C2 to c44 now that's my range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if that selects the data and
then we need to give the condition so
for example let's here give the name
which is Gill and then close this so
that basically tells me it is 5 times
kill appears here we can check this so I
can go in here I can add a filter and
then might be I would be interested
interested in looking at only Gill
and that basically gives me five right
so we can always do that and we can be
using formulas like this now what about
this question so which basically says
with sales representative made a sale
more than three times now we it might be
looking little confusing when I say for
example let me clear out this filter
now we have sales greater than three and
we would want to find out which sales
representative made a sale more than
three times now I could basically check
for every sales representative here if
they have made a sale more than three
times and what I can do is I can just
say equals I can start with count if
then I need my filtering criteria so
that's your range so first thing is we
will choose for example is choose C2 to
C 44 and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so I can choose the value here in C2
and then I can close this and then I can
say the sale has to be greater than
three and let's check so it tells me the
Boolean value that yes this guy has made
sales more than three times and what we
can do is we can just drag and drop
which basically gives me the value for
other sales rep you can always check the
value is automatically changing to this
value in cell and for example let's go
in here so this is obviously 2 so it
says me false right and you can
basically get the values for all your
values so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than three times
now like sumifs we also have countifs
where you can give multiple criterias so
for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the east region
after this particular date so we have
a date criteria we also have the region
criteria and we need to basically get
the count of number of orders which were
placed now I can in this case use count
ifs
and this basically says that you can
start with an criteria so it says how
many orders were placed from east region
after particular date so date is in my
First Column so for example I could say
a
start with 2 and say for example let's
go a 44 that should have selected all
the rows
and then I need to
once I have given the criteria range I
need to give the criteria so we are
saying
the date has to be greater than 10th Feb
so let's give it
to
10
2019
and then you need to say
how many orders were placed so you need
to give the criteria second criteria
range so we are looking at the number of
orders which were placed
from the east region so when I would
want to look at the region that's your
column B so I can basically say B2 to P
44
and here
I would basically
give my criteria so the criteria is East
let's give that
and once you have done this you would
want to find out the total number of
orders so let's select this and if I do
this it tells me 13 now is that right so
we are looking for your date
your region being East and then getting
the total number of orders so here I can
just do a count if I'm saying A2
to a44
wherein I have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th Feb because I do not want to count
10 Feb it says after 10 February and
then you are saying the region has to be
East so we would want to find out the
total number of orders so my region is
east and that gives me the result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times Gill
sold pencils so here we will have to
give the range so
let's start with count
ifs
now here I would want that item is
pencils so we can as well select column
D2
d44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil
and then we are looking for sales rep
which is Gill so
that is my column C so let's say c 2 2 C
44
and the value should be
just kill
so it tells me
it's twice where Gill has sold pencils
so we can obviously check this by going
in here
choosing my filter and then let's search
for rep being just Gill
okay and now we are interested only in
the item being pencil so I can say well
let's get to pencil only and that tells
me twice so you can obviously re-verify
using filters but using functions or
using formulas it is always good to
calculate and that can be making your
computation and calculation more dynamic
let's look at one more interesting
feature of Excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen conditional formatting has
different rules which can be applied on
your data and that allows you to
basically differentiate or easily
identify data values which are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you you can easily
manage these rules so conditional
formatting is very useful for people who
would want to work on huge amount of
data and easily perform some data
analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition you can perform conditional
formatting to identify cells you can
highlight a few significant cells and
you can easily perform conditional
formatting as shown on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look so
say for example we have our Excel sheet
and if you see here I am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
Revenue greater than 10 000.
so we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color and how do we get here so for
example let's select this data
and what I could do is
I could go into conditional formatting
now I could basically highlight cell
rules and and we could just say greater
than that's an easier way I could also
go ahead and create a new rule but then
I can use one of this option I can say
greater than and let's give some value
might be we would be interested in
looking at any value greater than 12 000
so let's choose 12.
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example I would
say something like
yellow fill with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what I'm
doing is I have all the values where the
revenue generated was greater than 10
000 but then I have also selected all
the sales people who have made or who
have generated Revenue greater than 12
000. so I can just do a Ctrl Z to see
the previous result now here I had the
values which were greater than 10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale so
if you look at the values here I have a
three color scale mainly in green yellow
and red and how do you do this so for
example I can go in here and I can go to
conditional formatting so I would want
to go for color scales and here you can
create different rules so we can set up
a two color scale so we can say format
only values that are above and below
average I can format only cells that
contain something I can get the top and
bottom value so these are different ways
in which I can have a three color based
scale now what I will do is I will
select this and let me show you the rule
which I have so for example I can go
into manage rules and if you see here
there are certain rules which have been
specified now what does that mean so you
would want to specify a three grade
scale so for example if I would want to
look at my first rule it tells me that I
am choosing three color scale I can
choose lowest value percentile and
highest value and that basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is I can
basically
use one of these values I can delete
these rules which I have created so for
example I have all these rules but you
should always carefully remember that
the rules will be applied in the order
shown so for example if I just delete
these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now it does not have any
highlighting now I can go in here I can
say conditional sorry conditional
formatting I could go for color scale so
I could basically go into
new rule so I would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red I can say midpoint
is percentile 50 and then the highest
value is green and if that looks good
let's say okay and now if you see the
lowest values have been highlighted as
red you have mid values and then you
have the positive value so this is a
three color scale and that easily helps
me in identifying the data based on the
cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can basically color
the cells based on their value so what
we are seeing here is if the revenue
generated is greater than average then
that shows in green and if the revenue
generated is lesser than average that's
shows in Orange now how do we do that so
we can basically again manage some rules
so I can basically create a new rule now
here I can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option I would want to select now I can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so in our case we
had it in green so for example I'll say
above average and then here I can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size so
let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow
say okay now I'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here let's go and look
into manage rules so this is basically
the rule which we are applying now we
can also add a new rule
and I need to select the values so for
example I will say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below we'll go for format we will
choose red we'll say okay we'll say now
these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if I select this and then I
could basically choose my area just hit
on enter and similarly you can go in
here and then select your area hit on
enter and say apply say okay and now if
you see I have really chosen bright
colors but then I have said wherever my
revenue generated is above average it
should be in yellow and
below average should be in Red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in Orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also find the top 10
and bottom 10 values and that's pretty
easy so you can just select this and
then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items or
you can go in for more rules so you can
say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10 now you can
choose the color and for example I'll go
for blue
and
I'll say okay so now if you see my top
10 values are blue now similarly I can
add one more rule so I can say new rule
and I can say let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay say okay and that's it so now
you have your values which are top or
bottom 10 values so you are using
conditional formatting where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors and here easy
conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what we can do is we can
select our columns either you could
apply this to all the columns now here I
have applied this only to Jan and April
now I could apply this for June so let's
say June so you can go for gradient fill
you can go for solid fill you can
obviously just select the color and that
takes care of the things you can say for
example select this and now this is
selected what I would want to might be
format this so I can go in here I can go
into manage rules now that will tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so I can just do a edit
Rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill which is color you have no
border this is basically color as black
now I can go for something like gradient
fill
and I can say okay and now if I say
apply and okay so this basically is Like
Your First Column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be here the revenue is getting
generated or was getting generated but
did not grow Beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can also go
in for different options say for example
here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going up for
this particular sales person so here we
are looking at Carol so in Jan the
revenue Generation by sales was very
high then in Feb it was falling down
in March it was kind of stable then in
April it went way below so we can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales you can go for Icon
sets and this is where you can choose
your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example I would be interested in
looking at the indicators like
directional I could go
using this three arrows I can go in for
this color I can choose directional and
then my values are
automatically using directional now what
we can also do is we can then go into
manage rules and that basically tells me
what rules have been applied so for
example the latest one is the icon set
which I have chosen it shows the
selected columns I can obviously do a
edit Rule and then I can choose so I'm
saying the format style is icon sets I'm
not using a data bar I'm not using color
scale now here
I have chosen the style of icons
and then here you can basically give
some values so you have icon which is
green when the value is greater than or
equal to 67 percentage
when I say hyphen or minus it is less
than 67. it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily highlight your
cell values based on this icon set so I
can apply this and that's how I use
conditional formatting so conditional
formatting can be very useful if you
would want to use icon set if you want
to use your data bars if you would want
to highlight particular values if you
would want to color code based on some
calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts or people
who are working in business intelligence
teams or people who would want to use
Excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value or finding out less
significant or more significant cells to
then pull out values and carry out your
computations calculations or analysis so
let's continue learning on using Excel
for various things now we have learned
on conditional formatting and seen how
that can be very helpful let's learn one
more feature of Excel and that's
basically your data validation now this
can be very useful when you would want
to work on validating the data which is
being fed in the cells so you could
limit it to basically a number between a
particular value you could also add some
messages to it if you would want or you
could even
Circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in Excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a Cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict that the name should accept
only 15 characters now how do you do
that so you can basically select the
cells or you can just select a
particular cell and then we can later
drag the property to other fields now
here once the cell is selected so for
example let's try this out and let's see
if that works so for example example I
will say Peter Johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
Junior
and if I do this it says input length is
greater than 15 do you want to continue
if I say yes right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has basically violated the
rule now this is giving a message to the
user that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that so for this we can basically select
the column and then we can search for
data Tab and get into Data validation so
this is where you can create or select
different kind of rules so for example I
can go into Data validation I can go
into settings and I can say the text
length and that should be less than 15
now this is the maximum I'm giving and
it says apply these changes to all other
cells within the same settings so I can
do this or I can just drag and drop so I
can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
Control Data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters it will pop up a
message if the user really wants to go
beyond the particular limit now you also
have similarly date of birth so the
Restriction is date of birth should be
between 10 Jan 1990 to 30 December 1998
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here I have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range that is 10 Jan date
1990 12 30 1998 so that's the start and
the end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now I can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so I can say stop I can say
invalid entered
and this is how I have set a rule so for
example if I just do something like this
and that says invalidate entered I can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until I did not give the
right format the date will not be
accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well I
would want to apply this rule to all
these rows starting from C2 to c14 so
let's get into Data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom now within custom I am
choosing what is the formula so I'm
saying is number
and then I'm saying find
at the rate for
the rows C2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for error
alert so for example we can basically go
in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title I'm giving and we can
say email should contain
at the rate
so if I do this and if I say ok now you
can test it so you can say A B C D and
that says email should contain at the
rate and basically that will not allow
me to add the values so now you have the
field called salary it says salary
should be greater than 50 000 now we can
limit the values by choosing a whole
number so for example for salary I can
go into Data validation I can go into
settings so here I can say something
like decimal or I can go for whole
number so both of the things are fine it
depends on what kind of values get into
this particular field so if I say whole
number and if I say it has to be greater
than 50 000
so I'm saying the minimum is 50 000 or I
could have given a decimal and then I
can say greater than less than equal or
anything or even between so I can select
greater than and then I can just say
okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will generally
not be decimal so this would be whole
number salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here and in rank if you
click on data validation I have chosen
whole number
I have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends I can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see I have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city names and then you
have places within that particular City
so if I would want to implement a data
validation based on this so for example
if you see here City and that basically
shows me only the four values which can
be entered and if I go to place then it
tells me for Maharashtra I can only
enter Pune Mumbai nashik now how do I do
this so say for example you take an
empty field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so I could select
data validation I could basically select
list and then it tells me you need to
enter the list values that is the source
so you click here and then I can just
select these fields now if I do this and
if I say OK it has implemented a data
validate but if you look into this it
will show me the same thing but then it
shows me some empty cells which did not
have any value so this is fine but it
would be better if we do it in a
different way so I can select this and I
have already given my city names here so
I can just do a data validation and here
in the source let me get rid of this now
I can just have my cursor here I can
select these values and then if I say ok
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to these values and
that's how you can Implement your data
validation so I have this data
validation here but I will get rid of
this one by just doing a control Z now
I'll come here and say for example I
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
e in doing this for all my four cities
now if you see here I have data
validation I could choose Bangalore and
if you come and check here there is no
data validation but we have implemented
data validation here now how is that
done so I could select this or for
example I can go in here I can select
data validation I can select list and
then here in the source I will say for
Bangalore the value should be these and
then if I basically say okay
now if we see these are the values which
are fed into Bangalore so we could do
this or like what we have done here so
if you can check the data validation
rule I have used list and then I have
said indirect F2 so basically I'm giving
in a formula which relates to the value
which is in for the city Maharashtra so
we could do this or in a simpler way we
could do this and then just drag and
drop here so we could check for
Maharashtra what are the values let's
choose a different city so for example
Kolkata and here I will choose now since
we did a drag and drop it has basically
taken the values of Bangalore so that's
not right so we select this we go into
Data validation and here I can either
feed in the values that is such as
Bangalore I could basically say
something like this Kolkata and I could
say okay so now if you see it shows me
the places in Kolkata now here we have
let's choose a different city so for
example let's go for Delhi and here I
can go to data validation and I can just
say Delhi so this is an easier way of
doing it or if you remember the formula
then what you can do is you can just
give in
indirect and then basically
give the value of the cell for which you
would want to keep in the values so this
is how you can do list validation so you
can provide a list of values and then
you can restrict the values in a Cell
which should be belonging to a
particular list so this is how you do a
simple data validation by restricting
the data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is one more very useful
feature of Excel and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis now pivot table is a summary of
your data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set and it allows you to group your data
in several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of items here it also tells me
the sum of sales
and basically it gives me per item what
is the total sum of sales which were
made now how do I get this here so for
example if I would want to delete this
and I would be interested in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the row end if I just do a
control and right arrow it tells me
what's my right last column and if I
just do a control and down arrow it
tells me there are
9994 rows now I can use this and what I
can do is I can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since I have chosen my first
row and First Column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
I'll say existing worksheet and I can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field and that
should be good enough so for example if
I close this or if I say ok so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table will be created now what are
the fields we are interested in so as
per the problem we need to find out what
the total sales for each category so
let's go in here and let's select the
field category now as soon as you do
that it shows that the rows
which are being selected are for this
column category and now we are
interested in getting the sales so we
would want the sales per category so
let's select this so you see some of
sales is selected now close this and
that's it that's that's your data so it
shows you row labels it tells you what
are the different categories
and it also gives you some of sales
which is per category now this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have another data set so again you can
just check how many rows we have and it
is basically the same
9994
and if I look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and here we would want to find out which
category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so we have some
categories here which says furniture and
it shows some sub categories and then it
shows me office supplies and then some
sub categories and same thing with
technology now we know how we got this
data but this is different than what we
were seeing here so here we were just
getting the categories what what we did
not have any breakdown of sub categories
within this particular category and here
you see there is a breakdown and then
basically you can also apply a filter
which basically says what is the data
you want and if you are interested in
finding out a particular value now how
do we do this so for example let me get
rid of this now we know how we can find
out the category of items but we would
want to find out which sub category of
items sold the maximum under each
category so here we are not looking at
sales but we are looking at the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and First Column
click on insert click on pivot table
data is already selected let's choose
existing worksheet let's choose a
location in our worksheet where we would
want to have this so maybe I can select
this particular field and then just
close this so it says this is the
existing worksheet say okay and now you
need to select your columns so for
example
if I would want the data for categories
so I can select this now I know that
within category these are the options
which we have and then there is a
subcategory so let's select that and if
you see here now we have the data which
will be filtered So based on your
category and sub category and then we
will choose quantity so it automatically
understands that this is something on
which summation can be done so let's
select this and close on this now if you
see here we have got our items where we
can see
the subcategories within a particular
category now I can basically close this
and that just shows me high level
categories here so here I can again
select a particular
row and column I can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected existing worksheet is what I
want so now I will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier so we will select
category subcategory and quantity so the
data has already come in just select
this and now you already have all your
data but this is not what we want we
want to basically apply a filter to this
now how do we do that so we can go for
slicer so I can go for insert slicer and
then it tells what are the subcategories
which you are interested in so for
example if I go for something like
subcategory and say Okay so this tells
me what are the categories you are
interested in so for example we know
that furniture has Furnishings with the
highest value so I can select say
furnishings and then I was interested in
office supplies So within office supply
I can basically
search for
here
binder so I can just do a control and
select binder
and then I can also know for technology
I can select phones so I'll say control
and select phones and now if you see the
filter has been applied and we have
these sub categories which are selected
so we have our data here now we don't
need really this so I can just delete
this and I have my data which shows me
Furniture being the main category and
that has only Furnishings office supply
having binders and Technology having
phones and that basically is a filter
applied on the result of your pivot so
this is how we are seeing which
subcategory of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region that made
the highest average profit now how do we
calculate that so for example this is
the data we have and as I've instructed
earlier you can select the first row and
First Column you can click on insert go
into pivot table and that basically
selects all your data we will choose the
result should be in this existing
worksheet so select this click here and
then basically let's select
this cell and I will say okay so now my
pivot table will be here so we are
interested in finding out top three
states within each region which have
made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select region so when we select region
it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state So within every region
you have multiple States so that's what
we are selecting and then we are
interested in looking at the profit so
let's select profit and that
automatically shows up here so we can
now say close this so basically we have
all the data but we are looking at the
sum of profit but that's not what we
want we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit now how do we change that
so here we have sum of profit so I can
do a right click and basically I can say
summarize values by average so now I'm
getting the average here and that
basically tells per region I have the
average profit but first is let's sort
this data so let's go into sort more
options and here I have average of
profit or for example as I said you can
select region say okay and now it is
basically having the
regions and then you have your state
value so again we can do a sorting here
and I can say
let's go for more sort options I'll say
descending the state values should be
based on average profit so let's say
okay and now if you see
in particular region we have the data
which has been
sorted wherein you have the highest
average profit on the top now what we
can also do is we can basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but I am not interested in top 10 so I
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region you
have the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your West now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and Central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort Z
to A if that's what you would want to do
or you can go for sorting more sort
options and you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending Z to A let's make it
ascending say okay and now you see the
data has been filtered so it says per
region now you can always select this
and you can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit now we
are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted within the region
and what is the average now we have one
more question what is the percentage
contribution of each sub-category of
products under each category to the
total sales so we know there are
different products there are different
categories and all the categories
contribute to the total sales so we
would want to find out what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory
of products under each category so we
not only want the category percentage
but we would also want what is the
contribution of each subcategory
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
in First Column click on your insert
click on your pivot table and now the
data is already selected existing
worksheet place your cursor here and
then let's select this cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category and then within
a category we will have sub categories
and we are interested in the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sump now we can click here
value field settings and it says if you
would want to summarize this it says
show value as and what are the values
you would want so you can straight away
go ahead here and say percentage of
grand total so we could do that because
we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now I could basically say
percentage of grand total say okay and
then just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
subcategories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells which subcategory is
contributing more than others we can
select how many subcategories we are
interested in so we can basically select
one of the subcategory cells right click
now you have option filter and you have
sorting so we can say more sort options
now here I will say descending and you
want the descending to be sum of sales
which is already showing as percentage
click on OK and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales it shows the sub
categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales so technically speaking if
you look at all these values which are
subcategories and if you would total
them that would be your total grand
total so this is how we can solve a
simple problem like this what is the
percentage contribution of each
subcategory of products under each
category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for home office
segment we are looking for customer
which made the lowest profit we are also
looking for the state as the main
criteria so in each state we would look
for home office segment and within that
we would look for customer which has
made the lowest profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this so
let's say let's get into selecting our
row and column we will go into insert
I'll say pivot table I'll say existing
worksheet and let me get my result here
so let's say okay now that gives me the
PO table so the first thing is we are
looking at per state
and I would be interested in
home office segment or I could first
start with segment now here we have
segment and in segment I can basically
select home office so I can just do a
uncheck and select home office only
and now I can select
state so that will be my
subcategory within segment and then
within State we would want to find out
the customer so let's get the customer
name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit and
here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this and now
you have your data
which basically shows me the names of
customers which made the profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this and
we have state entries also so that's
fine so what I can do is here I can
basically say sorting go to more sort
options I can say I want to do it
descending or I want to do an ascending
an ascending based on sum of profit so
let's do that now you see the top most
value is the lowest value per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state so how do we do that so we can
just go for filtering go for top 10
values I am interested in bottom value
and in that also I am looking for only
the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table
now say for example we have a question
which says find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order here as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice and then we would want to
create a pivot chart also so for example
how do we do that so for example I will
get rid of this
I will get rid of
this my Pivot chart which we can
recreate so find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions so
this is what we want now how do we do
this so for example let's select this we
will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet and
then I can select this particular cell
I'll say okay and now I am interested in
data quarterly so first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if I say order date
now
you see we have quarters and years which
are selected now we could be selecting
these fields which says
quarters years and if I would want data
to be filtered based on years I could do
that or I could get rid of here so I
have quarters I have ordered date
so
that's being already selected now what
else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region and we can also add region as a
column here so that will basically give
me all the regions as different columns
and then finally we want the sales so
let's select this
and now let's look what we have so if
you see here
we have our data which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels so let's
click on this so we have date filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016 and the value has to be 1 and then
let's select this and let's change this
to 2016
and this is 12th month
and then we can say 31
so we are saying the date has to be
2016.
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this and let's make it
date and say okay and now we have our
data which is
for
2016. so for example I could basically
select this and here I could be looking
at what are the filters we have so it
says clear filter from order data so we
have applied the filter on order date
and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 or this is wrong so this one has
to be changed to 2016. so select this
and now we have our data for 2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value or for individual
months in a particular quarter and we
have sliced the data now we could have
also introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if I would select a
particular field and then I could click
on slicer I could choose I would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to plot
a graph for this and that's very easy so
you just need to select the complete
pivot data and here you have the chart
options so let's go for line chart and
that basically shows me the line chart
so we can select this we can just drag
and drop it here and then we can
basically check if that is showing us
the data so if you see here this is line
chart where it has divided the regions
in different colors so we have all the
regions we could filter out in pivot
chart a particular region we have the
quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is
2016. in quarters it tells me it is 16.
so we have our data we have created a
pivot chart and basically we have sliced
the data for 2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram for
the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what I can do is I can
basically
select my row ID here and now I'll do a
pivot table so the data is already
selected I'll choose existing worksheet
let's select this particular cell say
okay now what are we interested in now
if you look at the fields we don't see
any years or quarters and so on so for
example here I can just choose order
date
and then basically
I can choose say for example years or
quarters the data which is coming out
from my order date so here I will just
select years
now
then I have my order date so
we are interested in the Years orders
and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select profit so that basically
says sum of profit but then I'm on also
interested in
for all the categories of products so
what I can do is here I have my field
which is category and that I'll add to
the columns so that shows me what are
the different categories
and this looks fine now I'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is I'll click on region
and here it says select all I'm only
interested in east and west so let's
select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered based on the
region so here we have region so you can
always look at the filter it is east and
west and we have our year data per year
we have different categories you can
always look at what are these column
labels so this is my different
categories and this is the profit per
category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this so we have our data for all
these years different categories the
profits made per year and if I would
want I could go into an year and I could
look into different months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so I can just place my cursor here
I can select this and then I can go into
insert and here I have different options
so we can go for bar chart we can go for
insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional let's select this and
here you see you can obviously select
different regions
you have your ears which shows up you
have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way let's look
at an example of one more useful
function in Excel and that is vlookup
now vlookup is used to see if a value
exists in a range of values and we can
create a range of values which is
nothing but a block of cells which has a
name and can be referenced so mainly to
use vlookup we need to create a named
range and that can be referenced
anywhere in the workbook or the other
option is you can always drag and select
the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also
other functions such as hlookup which
pretty much does the same thing however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically there are
other functions like lookup and X lookup
and so on so when we talk about vlookup
let's see how we do that so for example
this is the range of or this is the data
which has been given to you and here is
the question find the employee name with
employee ID 107. now assume that you
might have huge amount of data and you
may want to search something so how do
we do it now here I have created some
column and then some basic formatting I
have given it as an employer ID I have
given the employee name now what I can
do is I can create a range of data now
how do I do that or a named range so
what you can do is you can select the
data and then you can do a right click
now here you have something like get
data from table range so you can do that
you can define a name so you can click
on this
and here you can give a name to the
range what you would want to call it so
for example let's say our search now
that's the named range I'm creating and
just say Okay so the scope is workbook
and I've created a named range which you
can see here so it shows for search our
search so you have created a named range
now how do we do a vlookup here so for
that we can use a formula so for example
I would want to search for employee name
where employee ID is whatever you would
want to search for so employee ID we can
give here one zero seven now that's what
we would want to search the employee
name for an employee name is what we are
interested now what we can do is we can
use the function option here I can do a
insert function and that shows me
different functions which are here now
vlookup is showing up because I have
recently searched for it or you can
basically just type in here look and you
can do a go so that shows you all the
lookup options what you have like look
up Edge lookup match vlookup and so on
so we would be interested in vlookup so
let's select that and click on ok now
that basically opens up this function of
arguments and it shows what does this
function do so it says looks for a value
in the leftmost column of a table and
then returns a value in the same Row
from a column you specify by default the
table must be sorted in an ascending
order now you can basically say this is
what you would want to search for what
is the lookup value if you place your
cursor here it says what is the table
array that is nothing but the range
which we can use our named range here we
have the a column index number which
basically tells me what is the column
number in the range which we want so
what is the value we want from which
column and then basically you have range
lookup which basically is the fourth
option and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to give a particular value
which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name so I can basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee ID which is one zero seven so
what I can do is I can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee ID for which I would want to
search the employee name I could
actually select the cell here which is H
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so maybe
we can select this one which is H6 and
whatever value we key in here we will be
searching for employee name for that
employee ID now table array is we would
want to give a range so what we can do
is we can give our range so for example
we had selected something like our
search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee ID employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so I can just
say 2 and that basically is the column
number and then you have to give a range
lookup which is a logical value so
either you give an exact match or you
can basically give a closest match so we
can say for example do a 0 which
basically means false or you can say 1
which is true so let's go for zero now
that's our formula so it says vlookup
you will search for the value as per at
6 in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two and then true or false so let's
click on OK and that basically gives me
the value which is parallel
bunch
so here I'm searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this for
other columns and you can do that so if
it finds employee
ID here now say for example if we had an
employee ID somebody enters an employee
ID which is not in the range for example
let's try 121 and then you see this is
basically an error right because it does
not have any employee ID with 121 now
how do I take care of this so there is a
Formula which is called if error and
that can be used to take care of this so
if the value is not found then it will
show whatever I would want to
show here so what I can do is I can
still select this and what I can do is I
can search in function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is we
can test it here so for example if I
look in function and if I search for
error and say oh go so there are lots of
functions here and this is the function
we are interested in if error so if I
say okay now this takes the value and
what is the value if error so for Value
what I can do is basically I can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula and value if error
so for example I will basically say for
example not found so we can try this and
we can say okay now here it says not
found so whenever it is n a it is not
found now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of H7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if I would say 1
0 7 like earlier and then hit on enter
so it says panel of cruise and it shows
us the value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows n a and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what I can do is I
can get rid of
or I can basically take this one
now what I would want is I want this
formula to be here so what I can do is I
can say if error and then basically
given your vlookup option or function
here and then say for example not found
here not found now that basically will
take care of any kind of error if the
value is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if I say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but when
then we are also using IF error which
will take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable pound not
applicable replaced with whatever value
V key in
similarly we can do the same thing here
so we have the find the job title so we
are interested in finding out the job
title once the employee name is given
now employee name can basically have a
value from the cell or whatever value
you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with our vlookup so that's the function
we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here so that's
the lookup value and then you are
interested in finding out the job title
from the range so I will still give our
range which basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range and now I am
interested in finding out the job title
so that's column number four
and then I can just give 0 which is for
false so now we have given our vlookup
but that shows not applicable because we
have not given any employee name so we
can key in the value here which says
Fred Stone and now if we are basically
giving the value so Fred Stone now we
will have to search if there is any job
title which is Fred Stone so here is the
value so that should be showing up let's
check what has gone wrong so we are
giving our range we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was that when
we want to search for a value say for
example let's take this vlookup and
let's replace this value of H to L with
the value here so Fred Stone and then
basically we will give our range we will
say which is the column we are
interested in and then give true or
false so we can also basically take care
of this error message so for example
let's take this complete formula from
here and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for H6 which was employee ID now that's
not what we are interested in we are
interested in finding out the value so
let's take this one and replace this
with the value given here
and then I give my range I say which is
the column I'm interested in so I'm
interested in looking for job title and
then let's search so it basically tells
me not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example I go for function and
then I select vlookup and say for
example I say okay now just look at the
description here looks for a value in
the left most column of a table now
earlier the range which we had selected
had the leftmost column as employee ID
and that's why it was giving an error so
how do we fix that so for example let's
basically
remove this function from here now what
we want to do is we would want to search
for the stock broker now if you see here
I have given a range which is b 1 to D21
so we would want the value for what we
would want to search say employee name
that should be the leftmost column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data now am I
interested in salary no I am interested
in job title right so I can basically
just three columns and then I can define
a name so I can say our
search to and let's give a named range
and that's only because we would want to
easily reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say we lookup and
then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes so basically this is my
function we will say if the value is not
found then we will give this so you can
create an external structure and then
within your vlookup we will say the
leftmost column which we are interested
in so that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either I can directly select the value
here in the column b or I will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
then I need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your our
search too and then you need to select
the column number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give it 0
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now let's
try to find the job title of Fred Stone
so I can just select or I can say equal
and then I can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup we have also
used if error which basically takes care
of error message if the value is not
found so for example we can test this
here we have Fred Stone
so for example if I just empty this and
I point it to something which does not
exist so that shows me not found or if
you just select this and then key in a
value it shows you this might be we can
just type in so if I say Fred then
basically it says not found because we
are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this so there are different ways of
doing it so what we can do is we can
always go for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example I would be interested
in finding out
this one and let's give this so you can
search in this way so you can also have
statements which can be searching one
related to other now here the question
was to find the job title of Fred Stone
so let's type in Fred Stone and that
basically shows me the job title which
we are interested in so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started it's half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting to
think how horizontal lookup
works in the on the same lines but here
instead of vertically searching through
the columns the range is more of
horizontally defined so we search in
rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee ID you have
your employee name you have employee
email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees and then basically
you have the salary so this is the data
which has been given to you and you are
asked to search or you are interested in
finding out say the salary based on
employee name or job title based on
employee ID so what we need to do is we
need to define the range here now range
can depend on what you are searching for
so for example when I'm searching
employee name and salary so I am
interested in these four rows when I am
saying employee ID and job title then
might be this is the range and I don't
need salary so I can create a named
range if we are interested in so that we
can easily search for it or we can
straight away give the the first cell
value which is basically A1 here and
then the last value here which is G and
then you can give 5. so you can do that
or you can create a named range
whichever way you would want to do it so
for example we would want to create a
named range for our first question which
is find the salary of Eden Cornell using
H lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now like we did earlier we can
just Define a name might be we can call
it our search three
and we can just give okay so that's the
named range which we have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name so here we can insert our function
so let's look up and let's search for
look and just click on go so here you
have hlookup and basically that's the
function I'm interested in say Okay so
this says what is the lookup value which
you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name so for
example let's select this cell that
gives us more dynamism and you can add
in any name and you can search for the
salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is D 2. so we can give
Aden kernel from here so let's select
this now table array so we need to give
our range so let's say our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is 4 and the
range lookup will say 0 which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on OK and that
basically gives me the salary for Eden
Cornell now that's basically because we
have fed in the value here
and that is basically giving me this so
I can again do if error if I would be
interested in to basically take care of
L message if the value is not found for
that you can look into the previous
example which is vlookup now similarly
we are interested in finding out the job
title for employee ID
105 how do we do that so we need to use
Edge lookup well we could have done with
vlookup but here the data is more
arranged in the form of rows so how do
we do that so we can again use Edge
lookup but and we can give a range or
named range or let's for this time let's
basically key in our range manually so
we can do that so let's go for H lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value then we need
to give a range now as I said if you
would want to give a change manually so
for example I'll say a and then I'll say
a 1.
colon and then I'm interested in G and
then the row will be 4 so salary row is
not what we are we are not interested in
so let's say G and then we can give 4 so
that basically gives me the range right
instead of having a named range so we
can do that and then we need to give the
row index number so we are interested in
finding out the job title which is
basically in our range the fourth row
and then give 0 for true or false so if
you see here it tells if it is 1 it is
approximate match false is an exact
match and we can close this bracket that
completes our formula it takes the value
which is given in employee ID and then
it will try to search for the job title
so that basically shows wherever the
employee ID is one zero five the job
title is fabricated again you can use if
error
wherein your if error can then be
working on hlookup and can take care of
error so that if an employee ID is keyed
in for which there is no matching value
then it will not show you a not
applicable error in instead of that it
will replace with the word whatever you
have specified so in this way you can
easily use Edge lookup to search from
the range of data which is horizontally
arranged and in the previous example we
were seeing how you use vlookup when the
data is arranged vertically
so we have looked at vlookup and Edge
lookup and what we have seen is vlookup
has a limitation in one way that we need
to basically give a range where the
leftmost column is the one which is used
now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for so for example we have this
question find the salary of Hank
Saunders now that's the employee name
which we have here and we would want to
find out the salary so what are the
columns we are interested in so one is
your employee name and one is your
salary and these are the only two
columns which we are interested in so
instead of using vlookup now like I have
shown earlier you can create a named
range for these two columns and you can
use that or we can manually give the
range here so let's go for lookup
function here and lookup function will
basically help us in searching what we
are interested in so we are interested
in finding out the employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup I can
first give the value which is here
employee name now whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so we are searching based on employee
name then it says lookup Vector so we
will basically then say what is going to
be our lookup Vector so here we need to
give a range so what are we interested
in we are interested in finding out the
salary based on employee name so first
goes our range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example select this one so that's our
range B1 to B21 so that will basically
have the employee name in which we will
be searching for and then we are
interested in searching out the the
result Vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this and that completes our lookup
function so now if you hit on enter it
shows that for this employee where the
name is hunk Saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by basically giving
some other name so for example if I
replace this with say Fred Stone
and that basically shows me the value
for Fred Stone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is Hank
Saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of Lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
leftmost column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee ID of this
particular email ID so we need to again
use our lookup function so we'll say
look up now what are we interested in we
will search based on this email address
so I will select this then I need to
give that based on email address we are
searching the employee ID so email
addresses in this column so let's select
this range and then we are interested in
employee ID so then goes our result
Vector so select this column and that
basically completes your formula so
close this bracket and hit on enter so
that base basically shows me the
employee ID for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as I've explained earlier you
can be using the if error and you can
basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if error so basically this
shows how if error helps so say for
example as I showed in your employee
James Bond if the value is not present
display not found then what are we doing
we are basically nesting our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value given
in the cell H is not found then
basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is B1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions we are searching
for 2 that is the column number 2 here
that is employee name so check for
employee James Bond if the value is not
present or no so we are basically just
searching for employee name here and
then give your 0 or 1. so that's
basically usage of your if error which I
have shown earlier and the same thing
can be applied for your Edge lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example you
know instead of using your vlookup or
hlookup or lookup examples what we have
seen say for example you are asked to
find the salary of Peter Daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is Peter Daniels I can use a
vlookup however sometimes we may also
want to use a index match an index match
is also one useful function to do that
so we can basically search based on that
so we have to define the range of data
we have to then say what do we want to
match so that's basically an employee
name and then we are interested in
finding out
say for example based on the range of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here I can use a
function which is called index and if
you see here it says returns a value or
reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so I can say A1 all the way to E21
so that basically is my range now I
would want to find the salary of this
employee name which is Peter Daniels so
I can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically give it
correctly so we need to say match now
how does this match function work so we
need to basically match for a value so
for example we will select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
Peter Daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match in the column B which has
employee
names so we can give a range which is B1
to B 21 so that's basically within the
employee names we are looking for a
match which is given here that's in H6
and we want to do a match so we want to
do a exact match so let's do a comma 0
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically completes your
function and just hit on enter so that
shows me the salary of Peter Daniels
right so this is an easy way when you
can use the index function remember
first you give the range
and then you need to give your matching
conditions So when you say match I would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell I will search in the range of
values which is employee names I will
find an exact match and what I am
interested in is finding the salary for
Peter Daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee ID with salary 10 000
so you want to find out the employee ID
wherever the salary is ten thousand so
we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that so we can
start with our index function and within
index function we need to give a range
so for example I am interested in
finding out say for example our range
which is a 1
two e 21 so that's what I'm interested
in or you are actually interested in
searching based on
save your salary so you are interested
in searching the employee ID so maybe if
I just do a 821 let's see what happens
here now then I can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here H 13 so I will do a
match for this one now I need to give a
range
so let's basically give a range which
will be we are interested in
searching employee ID based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
I will say E1 to E21 that's what I'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine I mean we are interested in
finding out the employee ID based on the
match which is within this range
and then what we would want to do is we
would want to basically find the
employee ID employee ID is in my column
A so what I can do is I can additionally
give a match here
and then I can say I'm interested in the
finding out the value for employee ID
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give A1
all the way to E1 so that's the range in
which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
ID we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
ID where the salary is 10 000. so this
is how you can do your index matches
where you can give a range then you can
say what you need to match
within which particular column whether
it is an exact match or approximate
match and then the column from where you
are interested in finding out the value
so same thing we did here we basically
gave a complete range and if you closely
see we were only interested in finding
out the employee ID so here I give a
range A1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out match
basically will give your lookup value so
that's h13 then we gave a range which is
salary that's what we are interested in
and then we said when we are doing a
match we are only interested in finding
out the employee ID
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match so this is how
you can use index match instead of
lookup which can also give you uh some
exceptions and searching for specific
columns or specific rows now if error we
have already discussed where you Nest
your vlookup or hlookup inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions Edge lookup vlookup lookup or
index match to search for data some
function like this which shows up
xln.xlookup and then you're trying to
search for something so don't be
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using you have Excel 2013
team and say your friend has a new
version of excel say Office 365 or Excel
2016 and basically he uses a new cool
function and sends the file to you so
that's where you will have this
excellent prefix as I am showing up here
so for example what is the job title of
Xavier power is what you would want to
search and here the function which shows
up Excel and X lookup and then you are
searching so this is basically something
which is the function now if I just
select what it has selected here and if
I hit on enter it shows that this does
not work in my Excel here and that's
because of the version but what I can do
is I can fix this by removing this
details here and that basically shows
lookup we are searching for job title
based on employee name which is in this
field H6 and then we need to give a
range so we need to give a range of
names employee name and then basically
the job title range which is basically
the job title so now if I just hit on
enter it gives me the value so it's as
simple as that similarly here what is
the employee ID of the person with this
email we have already looked at the
lookup function so if it shows your xln
X lookup all you need to do is remove
this and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value based on the
range of values and then searching for a
value within a range of values so just
hit on enter and that gives you the
value and same thing goes for this job
title so what is the job title and
salary of employee name so we have this
function now what I can do is
here I am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do I fix this I can basically select
this and then just do a lookup based on
the values and it basically says you
can't change part of an array so we can
fix this now what we need to do is we
need to basically search based on this
particular value so we will basically
say I want to do a lookup now lookup
should be based on employee name
whatever name is given here then you
need to find the job title and salary so
for job title I want to find based on
employee name so I will give a range
and then basically I will say I'm
interested in finding out the job title
so I will give a different range
and then basically close this so that
basically shows now this is basically
because of the function which we have
here so basically to fix this what we
will have to do is we will have to
delete all the columns here which were
selected such as employee name job title
and salary because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function now what
we are interested in finding out is the
job title based on employee name so we
can select this cell which does not have
any value then we need to basically say
from which range or based on what you
want to search so we want to search
based on employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then we will be interested in
finding out the job title so let's
select the job title range and that
basically completes our lookup so let's
close this and hit on enter now it says
obviously error because this does not
have any value we will fix that by
giving in a value here same thing we can
do for salary so for example I can just
drag and drop it here and in this one
instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give so
the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary so we will select this
particular range and what we are
interested in finding out is basically
employee name
or we are interested in finding out
based on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit on
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example Eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix your
Excel FN error so same thing goes here
so it shows you xln is what you would
want to search might be if you don't
find something you would want to
pushing name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my Excel and then I have
lookup I'm searching based on h24 which
is basically employee ID you are giving
a range which is A2 to 821 because we
would want to find name not found
for a particular employee ID so I am
giving a range which is A2 to a21 I am
trying to search for the name which is
from B2 to B21 and then I am giving name
not found so say for example we can do
this lookup but then with lookup you
don't have this direct option what we
can do is we can use if error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range and
then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what I did was
I just use a vlookup so we know that
employee ID 121 does not exist so I'm
just using IF error I'm doing a vlookup
where I'm searching for the value given
in h 19 and then I am saying that I
would want to search from a range which
is basically B1 to c21 that is in
employee name and say email address for
example and we would want to basically
search for name not found so we can
instead of giving B21 or B1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just B1 to B21 we are
searching in column 2 we are searching
for exact value and if it does not fine
then it says name not found and that's
how we do it so we can always replace
and fix this Excel FN errors if
you are using uh some spreadsheet which
was or Excel which was sent by
um someone else who is using a different
version let's quickly see some more
examples of doing data analysis using
Excel and for that we can use some
inbuilt add-ins which can be added to
our Excel sheets so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive analytics
or descriptive analysis on your data say
for example getting your descriptive
statistics such as your mean median mode
and so on so we can do that and we can
use Excel for it so for example you can
if you are given some data say I have
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and I would want to have
descriptive statistics on this what I
can do is I can click on file and here
in file you can click on options and
within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have Excel add-ins
which is selected here so click on say
go for example and that shows what
add-ins are available and you can choose
which ones are you interested in so for
example I have chosen analysis tool pack
and solver add in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature
now if I do this and I have selected The
Heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this and then you can have your
cursor blinking here let's select say
Fields here and this is where I would
want the output now it also said what
options do you want so it has output
range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I am
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
OK and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on OK
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically
given a value for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for data
data analysis descriptive statistics say
okay now you need to give a range so
here I will change my range to these
values output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on OK and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to overwrite data in range
I will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new Range
so let's select our new Range which is
here and now click on OK so now we get
the values which is for your price of
ice cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier I can select this I can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this B2 to B8 and this
one which is H6 to h19 we would want to
shift it might be two columns up so
maybe I can just say H5 and I can
manually change it to a 17 and let's say
okay
and we will basically get this and I can
get rid of this so I can have it in the
same range so similarly so this one will
have to be renamed and I can basically
say price of ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I am interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from H to basically something
like J so let's say J and let's select
these values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
unit sold you did not have to manually
rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis using
data analysis here you can basically get
your descriptive statistics for your
columns and then you can do whatever
needed formatting you need to basically
make your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures you have
been given some pins where you would
want to identify how many values fall
into the range of 0 to 20 20 to 30 30 to
40 40 to 50 and the easiest way to do
that would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis where you would want to look at
different variables or say features for
example temperature is one such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see if the
increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find the relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to First do analysis on one single
variable look at the frequency of values
might we also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
parrot or chart so we can go for
histogram and that basically gives us
the frequency of values now how do we do
that so we have already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings and I have bin
range which is basically the range of
values so for example I can select this
and that's my bin range I am selecting
or the option labels because I'm using
the first
role which has the heading such as
temperature and pins now we need to give
a output range so for example let's say
I would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a Pareto
chart so if that's what you are
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I am
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on OK and now
you get your pins so it basically tells
you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we
can basically say there is 120 here with
the 20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20 then you have 20 to 30 which shows
three values so might be in that case I
can say 26
is one thing then I can say 30 that's
the second one and then basically I can
look at 22 so basically this one does
not select 20 as the lower range but it
basically selects 30 as a higher range
so I do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries similarly we can see values of
40 and 50 and since we have selected
Pareto or sorted histogram that shows in
a descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range
so that shows me highest frequency is 5
and then you have three and three and
then two so this is how we can create a
histogram and we can perform analysis on
a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as I said sometimes
we may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables are they linearly
related are they positively related
negatively related and so on and for
that we can use the correlation of your
data analysis add-in so for example you
want to find out correlation of
temperature and units sold and what we
can do is we can find out that using a
formula so for example if I search for
something like Co relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me and first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select the range of values
for temperature and then I am interested
in finding out the correlation of
temperature in units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is 0.2859 say
okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of values so here we are
interested in temperature and price of
ice cream so let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that let's close our bracket and
here we have the correlation value of
temperature and the price of ice cream
similarly you may be interested in
finding out temperature and units sold
like what we have done earlier so we can
do the same thing based on function so
this is same as correlation of
temperature in units sold so I can get
rid of this one now how do I do it using
the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into Data we need to click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now I might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
I've selected all the columns here we
will say Group by columns obviously we
need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on OK and that basically gives you
that basically gives you a correlation
of your different variables and what are
the values and we can check these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically temperature and price
of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149 you have temperature and units
sold so you have 0.2859 now you can also
look at units sold and say for example
price of ice cream you can look at these
particular values so if I would be
interested in finding out what is the
relationship between these variables I
can easily find using correlation so I
could be basically writing in a formula
here and selecting what are the cells so
here we were selecting A2 and C here we
were selecting A and B now might be I am
interested in price of ice cream and
units sold and if that's what I'm
interested in then I will give a range
of B2 to B8 C2 to C8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values so it's very simple in Excel and
you can use either the data analysis tab
and get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means might be I am interested in
range of values I am interested in
seeing a sample of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if I go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which I see here might be I want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or I
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly I would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do I do it so for example here I have
seven values now if I go for periodic
sampling
the sample or periodic sample value
which I need to give has to be lesser
than the total input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here and let's go for data analysis
so we can go for sampling here click on
OK and that needs a range of values so
we will select a22 A8 now I could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case I can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
I have seven values so what if I select
five so for example if I say 5 that
means
I could just get one value so basically
when I'm saying 5 out of 7 so that's
just giving me out of five I want one
value so I can then just give an output
range so here I can basically select
this cell I'll say okay and now you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is I have
said 5 it has given me the fifth value
that's your periodic sampling so for
example we want more values so let's
reduce this period to might be 2 which
basically gives me every second value so
I can basically say for example 2 and
say OK and then say okay so that shows
me 26 then you have 35 then you have 40
and then well this one does not have any
more values so that's your periodic
sampling now if you go for random
sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling I'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly I want three values
and I can just give this say okay and
then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this values of
temperature so we can use Excel to do a
simple sampling and we can choose
whether we would want to go for periodic
sampling or random sampling now we have
seen a sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression now what is
regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at two
or more variables and basically a
relationship of those variables with the
response or the Target right so for
example if we look at our data here we
have temperature we have price of ice
cream and then we have units sold and we
can go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics you have Anova you
have different plots which we have here
which is X variable X variable 2 and
then you have normal probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are independent variables
which one of these are dependent
variables right so when you talk about
your X and that's your independent
variable or we can say predictor or
explanatory so when you talk about your
independent variables or as we say
predictors or explanatory variables
these are the factors that might
influence the dependent variable and
when you talk about dependent variable
that's your response or Target that's
the main factor you are trying to
understand or predict so we can plot a
scatter plot to see relationship between
variables if they are linearly related
are they positively related negatively
related and so on we can also get values
such as R square which is coefficient of
determination regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so here is one of the links of
one of my edit other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
Spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
Excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold and then get
these plots so what we can do is for
example I can get rid of this
and might be I can just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal using your data analysis
add-in tool so we have been given
variables here now as I said when we
talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have multiple variables right so
you might have heard of univariate
analysis by variate analysis and so on
well here we are focusing more on using
Excel
to do our regression analysis so I'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as Basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do it helps you
understand how the dependent variable
changes when one or more independent
variables vary and it basically allows
us to mathematically determine which of
those variables really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so mainly the
goal of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about uh statistics we
differentiate between a simple and
multiple linear regression so you have
something called a simple linear
regression models which basically gives
you the relationship between dependent
variable and one independent variable
using a linear function and if you use
two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function because the
data relationships do not follow a
straight line we have to use non-linear
regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this might
be based on temperature price of ice
cream we would want to find out how many
units were sold now what we can do is we
can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
Excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert you can then choose the
kind of plots which you want then here
you have insert scatter plot so we can
choose this and you can choose the first
option so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want X values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about
why that's your dependent variable or
your response or Target so that is in
our case units sold and X values are 1
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here I can click on this
series X values and then I can select
this
now in y values what I can do is I can
select these and then I can just say
Okay so that shows me that it would be
giving me a regression scatter plot now
let's say okay and we have some points
plotted here now if you would want to
see the about and you have various
options here so you see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series and I would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your R square and that gives you
your Y and X that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
say scatter plot of uh dependent
uh West independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning and we can get
rid of this one so we have series and we
can say what are these points if you
would want to add in Legend if you would
want to do that or I can just get rid of
this and I will keep these values here
which we will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always compare these values so here I
have created a simple scatter plot
and then I can look at dependent West
independent variables
or I could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can hear
say for example just say Y and might be
here I will say x and we can rename that
later now how do we perform data
analysis or get into regression right
now what we would want to do is
we would want to get or we would want to
do the regression analysis to
demonstrate the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why when you
say y
equals you can say BX plus a plus c and
this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where X is your independent
variable Y is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y when
all X variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about B that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as X changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your uh
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically the
difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise right now what we can
do is we can also reduce this equation
to Y is B X plus a and that's the
equation of a line we can look into this
and the linear equation can be
understood mathematically in this way
now how do we do it in Excel so what we
can simply do is uh
here let me
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as I
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your X and Y so y being your target
that's basically your unit sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to X either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so I
will select temperature price of ice
cream and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels right now
we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that so you can say
whether you want it in a new worksheet
or you can just say output range and I
will probably just click here and select
one of the cell here now we can also
choose the other options which we would
want to see as a part of this regression
analysis so basically we have selected
input y range which is your dependent
variable you have selected X range which
is your independent variable and if we
are building a multi regression model
then we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals so
that basically gives you your residuals
now we can also get your line fit plots
which you were seeing earlier you can
also go for your normal probability
plots and then basically just say okay
and let's say okay and that basically
gives you your regression analysis
output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have Anova we have our serial
output that's from the previous one and
basically we can get rid of this that's
not required
I can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these so we have
our normal
let's get rid of these
get rid of this let's get rid of this
and then what we can do is since we had
some existing data it has overwritten so
let me get rid of this and I'll repeat
this step again
and let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis so we go get into
Data we get into Data analysis we choose
regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c x range is multiple
variables we have gone for labels output
range which we would want to select a
particular cell so let me select this I
am going for a serials line fit plots a
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this or to
understand what we have here where we
look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what Excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
Excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here and we
can
let's also fine tune this one
yeah we have our values here and if you
see we have our R square now we can then
basically look at our multiple R so what
is your multiple R that's your
correlation coefficient which basically
measures the strength of linear
relationship between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient it can be any value between
minus 1 and 1 and its absolute value
indicates the relationship strength
so the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and zero means no
relationship at all now when you're
looking at R square that is the
coefficient of determination which is
used as an indicator of the goodness of
the fit so it basically shows how many
points fall on the regression line so
your R square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about looking at the
value of your R square so it is
basically we can be seeing uh that this
is
0.450788 that's the value which I am
talking about so it basically means 45
percent of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words 45
percent of dependent variables that is
your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your X
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted R square it is the R square
adjustment for the number of independent
variables in the model so uh you would
want to use this value instead of R
square for multiple regression analysis
such as in our case
now you also have standard error so
that's basically goodness of fit measure
that basically shows the Precision of
your regression analysis so the smaller
the value the more certain you can be
about your regression equation so when
when we talk about your R square that
represents the percentage of dependent
variables variance that is explained by
the model and standard error is
basically an absolute measure that shows
the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that then you
already know what I'm talking about we
are just seeing how Excel easily helps
us in doing these things now we can also
look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your Anova values here
so we basically see DF you have s s m s
f and significance F now to understand
these so basically what we are doing is
or what Excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares into individual
components that give information about
the levels of variability within your
regression model so when you talk about
your DF that's basically the number of
degrees of freedom associated with the
source of variance you have sum of
squares that is your SS so smaller the
residual SS compared with the total SS
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about Ms that's
your mean Square you have f is basically
the F statistic or you can say uh f-test
for the null hypothesis basically it is
used to test the overall significance of
the model and then you finally have your
significance f which is the P value of f
so uh when we when we usually talk about
scene simple linear regression the in an
over part is not really used or it's
rarely used right but when we look at
the significance F value that gives an
idea of how reliably or statistically
significant our results are so if
significance f is less than 0.05 that's
5 percent our model is okay if it is
greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
locate looking at our intercept which
basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis is basically
your coefficients it basically enables
you to build a linear regression
equation uh in the form of y equals BX
plus a which I explained earlier and
then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12 the second one is 15 and
here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right so obviously there will be or
there would be some difference because
independent variables are never perfect
predictors of your dependent variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values so that's what we see
here in the residual section so for
example when we look at this one which
is 11.209 and the actual is 12 we see
what is the residual and how far is the
predicted value from the actual value
so similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables we
are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically uh add in
more details to this particular plot and
you also have normal probability plot
which is basically getting your values
from your probability output here so
this is how you can perform a simple
regression analysis and now what you can
do is you can as I said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y and x
and your R square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting and then you can
compare these with basically the values
what you see here so remember here I've
chosen my both set of variables and you
can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so it's pretty simple here you can add
more details to your scatter plot or the
plots what we have created or Some
people prefer to do it using formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as you have
linuist you have slope you have
intercept you have correlation and so on
so basically you can use these
particular functions and what you will
have to do is
you will have to basically go in for a
function if that's what you would want
to do and then you can search for
functions and say for example I'll just
say lynnest and say go and here I have
my function so if I would want to really
use this one I can do that what I will
have to do is then select the variable
so if you just say okay and that
basically says your known Y is known X
your constants your stats and basically
you can use the formula also but we are
not covering that here might be in the
later videos we can do that so just try
out and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of Performing regression
analysis using your data analysis add-in
in Excel well hello everyone this is
ifan Syed from Team simply learn in this
tutorial we will be talking about macros
used in Excel and also the Visual Basic
application programming for macros so
what is Excel macro you do certain daily
tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your Excel and use crop data
and you basically have the same things
performed or done on the Excel sheets
every time and every day or monthly or
bi-weekly or any number of times that
you open your Excel you remove certain
columns you add certain things and you
change certain values and these are the
things that you do and N number of times
on an Excel and this can all be done by
simple automated wave which is macros so
what it does is it is a set of tasks
that you can execute as many number of
times as you want when you create a
macro basically what it does is it will
record all your mouse clicks and
keystrokes basically if for example you
have your monthly accounts report that
is there and it comes every day and you
have to put it in extract certain data
and remove certain columns that you do
every time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the absolute values of your of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
and a simple running script called
macros so what you do is you record
those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macro
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of codes or a task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize whatever
click customize ribbon and then there is
a developer tab which you see here it
should be activated so you just need to
select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it all
on your Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing so here I have a work orders sheet
that I receive every day or one of you
will receive every day and how you
record a macro you have certain set of
tasks that you do and you know this
report has so many things that are
obsolete which you do not need which has
to be put across to your management or
your for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start recording your keys to
Strokes on the mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way I need to
go to the developer tab and start
recording the macro so when I click
record macro it starts recording my
mouse clicks and keystrokes so in this
sheet I have to you know remove some
columns and the columns that are
Obsolete and the data that looks weird
here should be removed and all what I
need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and the
requested workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work order
accounts and I'll add a little
description like
work order
account
costs
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the labor out the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts name I do not
want any of these obsolette data
so I just delete this okay and then I
just want to have some cosmetic changes
done so
and make sure this doesn't have any
border
and that's it this is the task that I
perform
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro C which we ran the just
now and I simply with a single click I
will be able to do these daily tasks and
execute in a Flash so I just click run
and it does the rest for me I have my
report ready and is in a proper format
that is required and it can be sent
across so here as we see it is done in a
single click by running a simple macro
continuing our uh to work on macro we
can simply do this by a single click of
a button by adding a button so what you
have to do is go to the developer tab
and in the control section you will see
the insert option option when you click
on the insert drop down you will see a
form controls and you can say select a
button and here I select a button and
the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
as a work order accounts just to make it
simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your macro so when I click
view macros it will show you what are
the macros that I have and that I can
run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same function that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is
bbba Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here
so as we see if you go back to the Excel
we see that our sheet we have been
working on the sheet and it has the
column still K and the actual sheet is
this so if I go to the Visual Basic
editor
and I'll make sure the note I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m and I just delete that
and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA in this tutorial we will be
talking about the Visual Basic
application programming for macros so
here we are what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
core application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks by running a
simple macro now to help us you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our abilities to ease our
work and automate our task we use VBA
so why we be there are many advantages
of using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel
so basically it is a very simple
language it saves time in performing
tedious tasks you have number of tasks
that you do every day as we have seen in
the previous section how we we can
simplify your daily task by just running
a simple macro and this VBA helps us in
performing those tasks in a very simple
manner another thing is it supports
english-like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic English language
statements and this can help us or it is
very easy to program our code or edit
these commands you can select a range
you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we'll
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the BBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail bar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window VBA code
window as it says is the code window
where your actual code resides wherein
you can go into it and edit the code or
write the codes and select the different
range of functions that you can perform
and this is basically the bdb VBA code
window where you edit your or write your
codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the the Excel sheets or
the worksheets that you're working on or
the modules that you have saved and so
on basically it is an Explorer for your
PBA like a Windows Explorer which is for
the file explorer the next thing is the
properties window properties Windows
shows you the properties of the
worksheet that you're working on for
instance here we are working on the
sheet2 and it shows the properties what
are the kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple lines of course individual Excel
code that you can run it will allow you
to test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging course uh the
output if the lines that you execute can
be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the you the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
Visual Basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the video basic I need to open the
sheet for you I mean the code window
filling and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window where
we we can run some testing course
immediately it will show you the uh code
so here we see the project Explorer
window where we see the modules and all
for our Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and columns
desperate but can I just save it click
okay
and it has started recording so now what
I'll do is as make it simple and I just
delete some columns here
okay I do not need this
I delete this is there a wait I want
this I want the amount of payment parts
cost labor hours I do not want this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and I go further left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrone
okay
I'm going to go back to my developer tab
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here so we see the macro here and
we can see uh in detail what it looks
like so we see the code what it's doing
and what the macro run has generated the
code back so we see we have basically
the name of the macro is format columns
and what it is doing we're just
selecting The Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee selected is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with N Sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
VB and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and I'll try to explain some
basic
functions and the commands and the codes
that we use to accomplish the task that
we with PBA
so as we see this is a blank sheet and I
have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as you see
as it starts with sub and I am
specifying the
module name as number so I'll just try
to make it quite simple and
you know so we as as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the how do the macro now uh I'll
explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what is it
used for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500. okay and here I'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limb keyword so where exactly I
want to put this you will see it when
you execute the code okay range I am
selecting it should be under course
where I'm going to put the value of x as
and I close the bracket and what should
be the value
we will value should be X so now as I
click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt or F5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain or example some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as a
double when double is basically a longer
form of single variable it usually takes
more space but uses needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set an
double and I just uh Chrome specified
and we can do state
it's basically stores the data values
okay and then again string so what
string does if you use string it stores
the text it can contain numbers it will
have some text as calculations or
anything can be performed so these are
the basic thing that I will cover and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
so in the next example I'll try to
use a string value for it and
I put it as a string
string so string
value
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I can get my code so I put a stream
book it has
okay
okay now
I'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select a Mac
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and 4 okay
so I close it
and I put I put a value what value I am
going to assign it is a country
okay
try to run this code right
I see G4 the name populates as a country
here so this is a dim keyword being used
as a string in our VBA code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using uh the
code here which I'm going to put
and we use the
okay
let's give it a value
foreign
keyword I'm going to use the
keyword as double
y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable ticks it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now I'm going to pop up a message in the
which says value of a is so and so so
I'm going to give value of a as
two five zero okay and how I it pops up
a message okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you want you can
enter the text and you can enter right
so here I'm going to uh write a code
which you know which gives a pop-up
message a message box saying that the
value of a is so and so
the value of a a
I'm going to put it in and percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay now that's it and let's try to run
this and you will see a message for
popping message box popping up
okay so the value of a is the message
box pops up saying the value of a is
250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it as
run with some procedures
[Music]
name
again game
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give anywhere I mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
this is the
report
let's make it simple
okay and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report for VBS so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I'm going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops a message saying that my name
is it fun so this is a message box that
you can display and I can do anything
with this
this is a PBA okay
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now I have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
number
and it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
value
is
tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I gave a range
of
I have to give it in codes
I'm going to
thank you
go to computer
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell A1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
4
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a uh let me show you one more
simple example where in a message box
pops up or a welcome message that can be
power set when you open the Excel or
worksheet so
so let's uh name it as Auto
open
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and
what does it say
I put it in quotes welcome
[Music]
Workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curve
so
rename it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I
am going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
cell
now I'm going to give it as V5
okay to put it as curves close the
parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to be 10.
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean let me make it
very simple here
I give it as B1
through b
5
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I'm going I'm specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay in the
and then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c one
[Music]
I mean another
error C4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis now what is the value that I
give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of C1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 has been
specified in the
code
so this is one of one more example
bearing you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
[Music]
seven
[Music]
I assign a value to it value equals
10. let's see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and columns have
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using BPA so I will show you
how
this is our
let's say selector
range it
and I am going to set a dim variable as
an example okay let's say it has example
and um what I'm doing is I'm specific
range because I need to select a range
of
cells okay now I'm going to set the
variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a one
to the
five
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and given give a value to it so
you can do it with the click of a button
on the VPN now I can simply tweak this
with the you know by just selecting it
so there is
I'll remove this
and instead of assigning a value I'll
just put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then it's it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or sales with these
probes
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set of another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay the worksheets
I want it in sheet 2 okay so I just put
it as sheet and I activated it basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
to
and what is the range that I'm going to
select the same thing okay
the range will be
will
be
A1
to D5
okay what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet too
and I'm activating it and I'm going to
assign range and I'm going to select it
so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
relate
[Music]
okay
so what I'm going to do is I am going to
select this range and I'm going to copy
it and paste it somewhere here okay so
let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes
and I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet foreign
selection and that selection what we are
doing is we need to copy it and now we
are going to specify the range where you
are going to
select it and then paste it quite simple
let's
okay see
and
you can just change it to so it is
visible on this
G5
okay
so this makes uh quite easy
and you can run it
uh the next scenario will be like
when you need to get the count or the
number of cells like you have to have a
selection and you need to count the
number of cells so this can also be done
and it's quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the summary account
sales
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you are using it and
I'm going to set a variable let's say
I'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we also we
will specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as a range and then
what we are going to do is
specify
this advantage or your selection where
you will count the where you need the
count of the number of cells so even
if the high hopes
and now how you want the output you want
it you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay
it says
okay here I think and list it so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
found in this event okay
now let's see I'm going to
selection so it's quite simple it will
be very useful in our daily task and
wherein you need to count the number of
cells so this is one way to get it
well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the count the number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
here
see it gives there are five columns okay
one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to
should give me
four four
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change it
to three it says six rows are there
okay
okay
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
one whoever is in programming are very
much familiar with this function so what
it does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check whether
that condition is there and if it is
space images if it is achieved then you
will have to specify the output as well
so this can be achieved with the if
statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so you it's not very
complicated and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met then the result
you specify the condition and the result
port okay so this is one thing and then
you can specify the s or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
two then the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Maps
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
let's show it again and
I specify as
okay
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have two variables I have a score
and I have a result and the score is an
integer the number and the result is a
string pass of a so I specify this okay
dim
score
as specified as integer okay
and then there's another variable that I
have to set
result
as
a
string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
score I am giving it as a range admin
it's in my
cell A1
okay
I specify the range what is it it is a
value
okay
should be erupt
okay
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
core value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
in quotes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay
and now where I want to specify my
result I should be
so I give it in the next column or any
one
this is the basic example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
space pass
to 40
.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
75 let's see how it shows
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifying the
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
here else
the result should be
it should be
okay
foreign
[Music]
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay this pass let's see
40.
put on it again
okay
so we are specifying two variables again
we are giving it a range and we are
specifying one condition if this
condition is met the result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use or we
are going to discuss is the Loop
statement that is the for Loop statement
and why we use it there are there are
situations and uh tasks that you need to
execute and you need to do it several
number of times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first treatment or the function
is executed and the next is taken up so
and then the next and so on so these
Loop statements allow us to execute a
statement or a group of statements
multiple number of times many number of
times and this happens only when the
first task or the first task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we'll discuss a simple
example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one
so here it is I have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it is
okay for x equals to 1 2
94 okay let's see
and I'm going to specify the range
as so what I'm going to do is basically
I'm going to fill the column A from 1 to
24 with some value not from 1 to 24 that
the values of 1 through 24 okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
one I'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up a an
integer a variable X as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1. and it
fills in A1 and then the next value of x
will be 2 and it goes to A2 and fills
the value as 2 so just let's try to
execute this and you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is going to be
24. okay so this is one basic example of
a for Loop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
sector for Loop and giving the output
and we'll code the output to be the
color code advance in the column B so
how we do it it's a basic simple example
that I'm going to take and again what
I'm going to do is I will have this
values here and I am going to convert
the
B column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see in
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is if you've select
it and it should color the interior with
what
foreign
X
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be colored and I'm going to put
it as a solid
you can fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
color B
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with p
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
we can perform tasks we can perform with
the VBA
and this can be found in detail
in our next process Advanced courses in
this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating our dashboards
we'll be using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo so this data set
was actually generated using a simulator
and is completely random it was not
validated though we have applied certain
transformations to the data using power
query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa there's North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representatives name or
you can say this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online
next we have the order priority column
now here C stands for critical then we
have H which is for high priority orders
then we have M for medium priority
orders and finally we have L which is
for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order ID the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this I'll click on a cell in my data set
and then I'll go to the insert tab here
we have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is
I'll drag my order here column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017.
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now let me show you how you can format
this chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y-axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let's go back to style
let's select a new style from this
I want
this die
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give two commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99
000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014 it reached 195
million
and after 2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table
I'll just click ok so that my PO table
is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go so we have our
next pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the sub-Saharan African region
in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa meet the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017. so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012 then in
2013
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as Revenue
by
year end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format access
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now will see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select
my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column all right so here we have
the pivot table ready now based on this
pivot table let's create our pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview preview of the combo
chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add data labels so I'll click
on data labels here
okay so these are the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options so I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this
makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet and create
our pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and here you have pie
chart
I want to select this 3D type of pie
chart and I'll click on OK all right so
we have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it
and from here I'll remove the field
buttons
and also don't need the Legends I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I'll click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now let's create our horizontal bar
chart I'll go to insert click on pivot
table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows
and then I'll choose total revenue and
place it under values
so here you have the different country
names we have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India this Jamaica Italy and all
the way to the bottom if you go we have
New Zealand this Netherlands Philippines
Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our people chart so I'll go to
insert and select recommended charts
from here I am going to select the
column chart you can see the preview
here and let me click on OK
all right so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style six okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so let's
choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time I am going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different item names and
then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so you can see
here office supplies meet the highest
amount of Revenue followed by household
then cosmetics and fruits meet the
lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time I am going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I've selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I have edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I am going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
all right
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Central init
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see ship format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so my text box is transparent now and
I'll also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
30.
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
card and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so I've also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format
and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline you see this so we have our
total revenue by year which is a line
chart and this is completely transparent
now now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box
so I'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so I'll
click on illustrations and here I'll
choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape
here I'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say 20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the axis labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add this blue background to
all the other charts so we'll first add
the background make it transparent and
then we'll convert the font text to
white color to make it more readable and
visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard
so I've added a few logos for each of
the
charts you can see the logos here so for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year in region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down
you have numbers
and under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
Tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or if you go
to the pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have insert slicer and
timeline option so I'll select insert
slicer here first now it's giving me the
list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region
and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values so under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have all the pivot tables that we
created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slices we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers
so I'll right click on this go to report
connections and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer I'll go to report connections and
let me select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
good report connections and then I'll
select all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
this chart represents the revenue that
was generated in each of the countries
only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channel so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied different formatting we
added different icons then we formatted
the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
Now we move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and
pivot charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so I'll drag my
total profit column two values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
2014
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country name so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
I'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
and Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right now we want to create a map
out of this the way to do is
I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top
and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
now as you can see our map has a color
scale which comes from light gray color
to dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can see light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this mapped to
the original data source so what I can
do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that I
had created
go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
the countries that made least amount of
profit
okay
now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel so for this we
are going to create another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column to rows
and then
I'll choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here based on this
pivot table let me create my Pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and I'm
going to create a line chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly
in year 2012 the Online Profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say SC for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivot
table and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here and click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's just see which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally I'm going to create a report
that will show the revenue and profit by
items
so I'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building our dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
will continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now
we'll insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustrations
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see I have brought my
Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of Revenue
now we'll copy each of the charts that
we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard so
let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I've also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid lines
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I'm going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
by labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
I've also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts and
I'll go to insert under insert I have
the option to create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I am going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
similarly I'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
I'll resize this and I'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
I have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is view table number 10 I
click on OK
similarly let's create or connect my
region filter to all the pivot tables so
I right click go to report connections
here I'll
choose all my Pivot tables which are
based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on OK and similarly I'll connect
my timeline as well I'll go to report
connections
and I'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts
I'll go to insert click on slicer and
I'll select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017
suppose you want to know the profit that
was generated in the year 2012 so I'll
just click on this range and now you can
see our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
2012
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
no if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
be checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by a Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
suppose you want to see the profit by
different countries so you can use the
country slicer let me just bring this to
the middle and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly office supplies item
meet the highest amount of profit in
United Kingdom now you can also select
multiple countries let's say
I want to know for France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly
now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually
not millions that should be in K that is
Thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually K and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see a chart
has changed let me just delete this okay
so now once you change the theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I am going to choose
depth
and this is more
of a green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects all right
so in this demo we saw how to create a
revenue dashboard so we created line
charts this combo chart pie chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charge and then we learned how to
add slicers and connected to different
pivot tables and we filtered our data to
see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here I'll be discussing some
important questions that you will come
across when you finish interview for
Excel and we will start with the basics
the beginner level and most of them will
be discussed here will be the beginner
level at the beginning and then we'll
discuss it at the further left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in Excel so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have an
Associated column number column letter
and a row number so you have to keep in
mind it will be always be a column
letter and a row number each Excel sheet
will have suppose for instance if you
take Row 5 rows will be in numbers and
the columns will be in letters column a
column B column C column D and so on and
the numbers will be for the rows so for
instance if you take this particular
cell the cell address is D5
row column D and row 5.
so this is the cell address now let's
move on to the next one
now you will be asked what is relative
cell referencing and absolute cell
referencing in Excel so relative cell
referencing is usually the relative
references change when a formula is
copied to another cell depending on the
destination's row and column okay so
this is called relative cell referencing
absolute cell referencing irrespective
of the cell you know you don't have to
depend on the value of the cell
destination there is no change when a
formula is copied so this way I'll
explain it in the next Slide the basic
difference is this type of referencing
is there by default in Excel relative
cell referencing you just insert the
formula you don't need to put a dollar
sign in the formula whereas absolute
cell referencing if you don't want to
change in the formula when it's copied
across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add or Dot
dollar sign before and after the column
and row address so see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as A3 into B3 so
what it will do is it will multiply A3
and B3 and it will give the product this
is relative cell reference whereas
absolute cell referencing is again the
same thing but you have to put a dollar
sign before the column and the row
number so here you are specifying this
as a pre into B2 okay A3 into D2 and it
will give you this particular answer
irrespective of that it will give you it
will calculate what is there in this and
it will give you the answer
okay now we need to move on to the next
point is basic question when you go
scroll across an Excel sheet sometimes
you have a header on the first row and
if you scroll down you will not be able
to see the first row so there is a
process uh or the there is a trick to
freeze the pains in the Excel so you
just need to have the rows locked so how
do you freeze paint this is the question
so what you need to do is you need to
select the view tab go to the view Tab
and go to freeze panes it's a basic
thing and you will see this if you see
here
select the third row and click freeze
pins so you just select this and click
free pay
okay so you're going here and you're
going to the third row and you are going
to view Tab and you are selecting free
Spin so what happens is first two rows
will be locked
okay
these two rows will be locked similarly
for if you want to freeze the columns
okay it's the same thing I am going to
select this particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pin so what happens is the first
two columns are locked A and B will be
locked and if I scroll right you will
always see the customer name and
category column so these two we have
logged and the next will be scroll so
this is the function of freezing panes
okay now coming on to the next one and
you will be asked
and you have an Excel sheet or a
spreadsheet and you want to restrict you
want to protect the data for from anyone
or from someone cop from copying the
cell for your worksheet so how do you do
that you need to select that particular
data that you want to protect and then
click Ctrl shift F and then you will see
the protection tab okay you just need to
go to the protection Tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you you need to select
the sheet put a password and just save
it so I will show you across in one of
the examples here so this is particular
uh data that you have and you need to
protect you select it
so here as I said I selected it and then
I just press Ctrl shift F so here you
see the protection tab click the
protection Tab and then click select and
then locked and then click OK and then
you need to go to the review Tab and
then click on the protect sheet and
you're having the you need to select
this protect worksheet and contents of
Log search so if you are selecting these
and you are protecting the content and
you just need to put some password
okay and then click ok
so this is how you protect the data on a
worksheet and you are selecting this
area Ctrl shift F and just put up a
password and select lock sheet so this
is how you protect the sheet from anyone
to copy it second
and now the next question that you might
be asked is what is the difference
between a function and a formula in
Excel
so you will be asked this question and
you need to remember this formula is
like an equation which is typed in by
the user you are typing it suppose a 1
plus B2 you are typing this formula in
one particular cell okay whereas
function functions are predefined
calculations it is like a formula which
is already there in Excel and you can
use it so as it says here it consumes
more time and it has to be typed in
manually you this is as per the need
basis and this is particularly it's very
quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in Excel the sum and
multiplication product and various other
things that you will come across so this
is the basic difference between a
formula and a function in Excel okay
the now the next question that you might
be asked is uh or you need to know
basically is the order of operations
used in Excel while evaluating the
formulas so what is the order you need
to remember this acronym padmas p e d m
a s or another simple terms you can use
this also please excuse my dear and
Sally so these are the acronyms p e d m
a s now let's see what happens first and
you uh in math when you do some
calculations you have order of
operations okay bod mass is the one of
the order of operations now in Excel
similarly in Excel when you put up a
formula you Excel will calculate it in a
particular order and this is called the
order of operations and the Order of
Operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any X exponents in it
and if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is any multiplication
or division so p e d and then it will
see if there is any additional okay and
then the last one will be the
subtraction so Excel knows this and you
have to know this so that when you put
up a formula you will know what is going
to happen first and you will not mess up
with your formula okay this is the order
of operations it is one of the important
questions in the interview for a
beginner Excel level now the next one is
how will you write the formula for
following multiply the value in a cell
A1 by 10 and add the result by pi and
divide it by 2 it is quite simple okay
so I'm just giving it as an example in
this slide and you might be asked
something else so you will be given a
task to calculate or put up a form the
purpose so when you are asked multiply
the values in a Cell of A1 by 10 so this
is particularly okay A1 is the
particular cell that is being given and
you are multiplying it okay you put it
in parenthesis and then add the result
by 5 so it will calculate the
parenthesis first okay and if it sees if
there are any exponents you have to
think in that way if there are any
exponents in it or not and then
first it will see the parenthesis and
then exponent there are no exponents
here and then it will do the
multiplication and then the addition and
the revision okay so you will get this
particular answer and if you put it
simply in this way your answer is wrong
because it will multiply it into 10 add
5 and divide by 2. so you have to check
which one is right and you have to make
sure that you are putting the right
pattern cases Okay so
this is the homework okay
the next question is uh there is a
different what is the difference between
count counter and count blank these are
three particular important things that
you need to these are similar but they
are quite different when you actually
see it okay so first we will see what is
count count is basically it counts the
number of cells which have numeric
values as the name suggests it is count
it will count the number of cells which
has numeric values okay if you see this
column and we are at a11 we are putting
it as count equals to a 10 to A2 to 8
and so you are taking this range and
you're finding out what are the number
of cells which have numeric value if you
see this one two three four five so five
cells have numeric values it counts the
cells which has numeric value and the
next thing is the counter okay what
counter does it counts the number of
cells which has any form of content it
can be anything it can be a number it
can be a alphabet it can be anything it
will see what are the number of cells
which has any form of content okay for
example this is the same example we here
taken here and we have put the function
as counter A2 to a 10. now see one two
three four five six
seven so it sees that there is
seven cells have some content in it it
is numbers and letters it can be
anything but it has some content so
counter is the pension for this then the
next one is Count black okay as the name
suggests it will count the number of
blank cells only
so again the same examples count black
A2 to a 10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two cells are
blank so it will count the number of
blank cells only okay now the next one
is uh what is the shortcut to add a
filter to a table why do we use filter
and it is one of the basics uh function
in the Excel where you need to do some
sorting and it can be done by using a
printer what is the shortcut key it's
very simple control shift and L this is
the key that is used to put up a filter
you just press this
Ctrl shift L all together and you will
find the filter and you can sort it now
the next question that you will come
across is how do you create a hyperlink
in Excel so it's quite simple there is a
simple shortcut Ctrl
key you press these two together and you
will get the option you will select the
it will select the cell where you have
to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to any other
document it can be a web page it can be
a Word document it can be another Excel
sheet or so on okay so these are the
things okay
now another important questions uh that
is how to merge multiple cells
text strings in a Cell so how do we
merge the text strings in multiple cells
into one cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatenate concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells okay and it's a very
simple thing you just need to put this
equals to concatenate and then if for
example this is the formula concatenate
text one text to textly or this is
concatenate A1 comma B1 comma C1 this is
the data in our three cells Excel is fun
in A1 V1 and C1 so now if you want to
put them all in one and you can merge it
in one cell using the concatenate
function and it's very simple
concatenate and parenthesis A1 comma P1
comma C1 okay and you will get it all
merge in one particular cell okay so
this is how you use the concatenate
function and you can also use the and
operator to combine cell values it is
the same thing you can use e and
operator instead of Commerce okay and I
will show it to you in the example here
okay now we have this I'll just copy
this thing to
yeah okay
and let's make it simple and now I want
to put this here equals
foreign
comma B1 comma c i just close it and I
put enter so you see this this all three
the different text is merge in one
particular cell and it will you can
perform various merge functions using
the concatenate function it's a very
simple thing and it is a frequently
asked questions in the interview okay
the next question uh it is very a very
important one again and a very basic as
well so how can you split a column into
two or more columns you have some
particular text or a sentence written or
data written in your cell or a column
and you want to put them across in two
or more or many number of columns so how
do you perform this function it's very
simple again you need to select that
particular cell so for instance we have
it here is India is a democratic country
India space is space the space the
Democratic space country so the it's a
different text here and you want to
split this particular sentence into
different columns okay you need to
select that cell and then go to the data
Tab and then choose text to columns
there will be an option when you need to
select text to columns okay and you will
see this screen okay and you need to
select the choose the delimiter here and
what we are specifying here is first it
is a delimited and then we are selecting
a delimiter as space because we see that
that is space here which is very common
and we want to split it so you will see
a preview here which shows what your
output will be like India in one column
is a democratic country so the diameter
is space here and T you need to select
this and then click next Okay so so you
will see the options select the columns
data format and choose the destination
now you see the data View and you need
to select the destination where you want
to put this output as and you select
that and then click finish and this one
what it does it it's it splits the text
into multiple columns okay so you see
this you have selected this as the
output and it starts here India is a
democratic country so you will come
across some data which is you know here
and there are spaces or objects or
anything that is differentiated it with
and you need to put them in different
rows or different columns so this is the
function r that you need to use to split
the text into different or multiple
columns okay okay the next question can
be very simple one or most widely used
in fact and what is the use of vlookup
and how do we use it so what is this
particular thing in Excel vlookup
function is used for looking up a piece
of information in a table and extracting
some corresponding data or information
so you have some set of values in one
particular column and you want to
retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular column
or a cell in the code sheet okay so the
syntax is something like this it is you
need to go to one particular cell where
you want the output as and you type the
function
vlookup and you are selecting the value
where it is the cell exactly where you
want the output to be and you are
selecting the table here and the you are
specifying the column index and range
lookup so value this indicates the value
that you have to look for in the First
Column of a table okay and then the
table table basically this refers to the
table from which you have to retrieve a
value we will show this in the example
in the next slide and the column index
column index it provides the column in
the table from which we are to retrieve
a value okay we will specify the column
index which one you are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true with the if you put true
it is approximate match which is default
and false if it is exact match if you
are looking for the exact match so what
is the use of vlookup and how do we do
it okay so frying the product related to
a customer name Richard okay you have
this sheet and in this one you want to
see what Richard has bought okay what is
a product that that he has bought and
you can do this with the vlooker
function okay so you just go here and
you type in the function vlookup you're
naming it as Richard
and first thing is the value it is H4
okay and then the next thing is the
table okay table is A2 because this is
the table okay and you're looking for
customer name Richard
okay and then you are selecting this the
whole column index which is E15 I mean
you are selecting this whole table then
15 okay e 15 okay selecting this and
then the next thing is option which is
giving you the uh range lookup okay what
it does is it's optional it is you are
looking for an exact value or an
approximate by default it is approximate
match so how it performs the function
okay so it gives you the answer as
scanner it goes and lookups for Richard
in this particular it will give you the
output here and the A2 is the table that
it will look for the customer name and
it will search for Richard and then it
will give you the half dash camera now
the next thing will be vlookup different
from lookup function how different they
are we look up lets the user look for a
value in the left most column of a table
so as we've seen in the example it
allows you to look for data in the lack
moves column of the table and Returns
the value in a left to right okay it
starts in left to right lookup function
lets the user look for data in a row
column and Returns the value in the
another row or column it will give you
the lookup function in the next workout
okay not very easy to use as compared to
the lookup function okay as we see uh
it's a bit complicated when you compare
it to the lookup function it's quite
simple and it is used to replace the we
dookup function okay so this is the
different lookup and vlookup function
now Excel is basically used for
reporting mainly used for reporting to
management you have to extract different
kinds of reports and what are the report
formats that are available in Excel this
is one of the important questions again
for a beginner level and there are three
formats basically compact form outline
form tabular form okay these are three
formats that are available report
formats that are available in Excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does IF function work in
Excel okay the F function in Excel it
actually performs a logical test and you
will give a condition it performs the
test and returns a value if the test
evaluates to true and another value
which you again will specify if the test
result is false okay for instance we
have here a simple example which is
shown in the slide and what we are doing
here is a written record is valid if age
is greater than 20 we have age here
specified and salary is greater than 40
000 as written the record is n value so
we are giving two conditions and it
actually checks and evaluates whether
these conditions are met and it will
give you an output whether record is
valid or invalid based on the two
conditions that are specified okay and
F22 axis which is this this column we
are specifying it should be greater than
20 and G2 to G6 which is the salary
column and we are specifying the
condition to be greater than 40 000 So
based on this two things it will check
and perform if these conditions are met
then it will give the desired result
okay so this is the function that is
used in Excel IF function okay the next
thing is sum IF function okay again the
sumif function adds the cell value
specified by a given condition or a
criteria so you are giving a condition
and you are actually doing another
position which is performing the
addition okay it will add the cell
values based on a condition again it is
shown here the total sum of salary where
salary is greater than 75 000. again for
example the salary column is G2 to G6
and we are doing a sum F function what
the result will be it will perform the
addition of salaries which are greater
than 75
000 so it will see which values are
greater than 75 000 and then then the
output will be it will be adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next slide we will
discuss another important function
counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the countif function so we have a
slide data here and using the Kobe data
find the number of days in which the
number of deaths in Italy has been
greater than 200 okay it's not shown
here for some reason but I will show you
in the Excel sheet okay so this is the
data that we have and we will try to
find the function so we'll use the
counter function and counter function is
again simple counter you are specifying
the column that is the source that you
are looking for that is G2 the column G
and it is 2. it starts from 2 Row 2 G2
till G three five triple seven which is
the end of the column and what you are
looking for is Italy you are specifying
it in quotes Italy and that's the next
column that it will look for is the E
column the number of cases okay here we
have the number of cases e 2 2 again we
are specifying the range and what we're
looking for is number of cases which are
more than 20. so we'll perform this
function and it will show you the output
okay I'll show you to you in the Excel
so here is the sheet and I will uh try
to get the answer here and
the
so we are performing count
okay
and you're giving the brackets
parenthesis G2 which is the
countries column okay countries column
here we'll specifying the whole range
three five triple seven
it is beginning a long a long list of
data and you're specifying the page and
what you're looking for is particularly
any country you can pick up like Algeria
okay
Algeria and you specify it in quotes
okay
comma
then what is the next Target that you
are looking for is the column e various
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay so you specify the column range for
the number of cases which is again e and
then
uh
the three five triple seven I mean it's
a basically long list data that you're
looking for and then you are what is the
condition that you want to know and you
have to specify it in course and what
you're looking for is number of cases
which are more than
can you hit enter
okay so it gives you the output as 143
so there are 143 days in which the
number of cases were more than 20. so
let's refine our search further let's
see 30. and it gives 140. so another
example that you can take is let's pick
Afghanistan
Afghanistan and click so for about 19
days that you will see the number of
cases where more than 30 and this can be
done with the count F function
so the next question is uh about the
pivot table
so what is a private table it's
basically is a summary of table of the
data set I mean the data that is there
that can be you know multiple number of
rows and columns which has different uh
data that has to be that is there in the
reports and you need to analyze those
Trends and you need to create a report
and basically present it to the
management or in a presentation so pivot
table is a summary of table you know
whatever data is there you can put it in
a summarized format they are useful if
you have long rows or column that hold
values you need to drag okay so you have
long list of data and you need to
summarize it and put it in a
presentation or a you need to track the
values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data and then go to the insert Tab and
select pivot table okay and then it will
show up like this and you need to select
the table which is a table or range and
then you need to specify where you want
to put up this private table okay and
it's quite simple and I can show it to
you in one of the examples Okay so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate our as
we have seen in the previous slide you
need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the pivot table and then once you do
that you will see something like this
and you need to select these particular
fields and put it in value so it will
for example you need to select the depth
number of death you can just simply
click this select this drag and drop it
in the values okay so these are the
different fields that can be put up in
the table okay we can show it to you in
the example here
so this is our data and we need to show
it in a view table okay select this and
then go to the insert app and click
private theme okay
select that and it will show you the uh
table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay I will put it in the
existing worksheet okay and I'll just
select which color I'll put it here for
example and it will show you this and
click ok so this is the table and now
you need to select the fields that you
want to show in the table for example we
need to see the continents the number of
cases as per the continents okay I
selected and put it in the row and we
see the immediately we see it in a table
where you see the number of names of the
continents and now I want to see the
number of cases and I simply select it
and put it across in the value so this
is quite simple and very informative
very short and crisp
form of presenting the data in
a private table okay so this is how it
is being used and it is being presented
you just need to go to the insert tab
pivot table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
so the next question here is uh how do
we create a drop down list in Excel this
is particularly useful when you need to
sort a particular data with the drop
down list where a number of different
variables are there and you need to
select one particular uh field and sort
the data so you can do this by creating
a drop down list using the data
validation in presenting the data tab
it's quite simple you select the data
and you go to the data validation tab in
the data and click select data
validation so once you select that it
will ask you to specify a range so you
need to select what data you need to
sort and put a drop down so we need to
select this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay I'll show it
across in the Excel for example what we
have here is some particular data and we
have different variables we need to sort
or put a drop down list so just go to
data as in as said in the slides and go
to data validation and click data
correlation now as you click it it will
ask you to data validation settings okay
and in the drop down go and select list
option so it will ask you to specify the
source so when you ask to specify the
source just click this particular column
and click ok so here I'm mentioning the
source is column B okay B 3 t b 14 Okay
click OK and then it will give you the
option so here you can uh you can put
this in anywhere across the Excel and
click the option okay so this is the way
to drop down using the data validation
option so in the next example we will
see so how do we apply Advanced filters
in Excel we use the advanced filter
option present in the data tab so this
is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of datas and you need to
sort it and it's it's actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field with this criteria and you
can select it and specify the criteria
and specify a range what you want to
uh select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified and you can just
get it in a single click so this is the
option you have to go to
data tab Advanced and you have to apply
the advanced filter and then you need to
specify the list link that is the is
killing the source then the criteria
wherein you specify the criteria present
here I mean you are specifying in this
case we will take an example where we
are trying to sort the data or the
number of cases based on number of
deaths and in a particular country and
we are specifying the output the copy to
field is the output where you will see
the output so I'll show it to you in the
Excel so here we have a spreadsheet
wherein you will see all the uh data
copy data that we have and based on the
countries and the continents and the
number of deaths number of cases and so
on okay and that's also a different
fields like the date year and month you
know so so here I am going to sort the
data which is particularly for Europe
and which has that's of more than 200 in
a day so how do we do it go to data
Advanced and the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list
screen so it's basically given in this
countries okay and the criteria range
you have to specify this so I am going
to select this as my criteria okay and
then I have to put the output in one
particular cell so I need to select it
again let's say here okay
and then I just click ok
see it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay so it shows me the deaths
which are more than 200 and for which
particular country and for which
particular
continents are all right so this is
basically made very simple with this
option the next question is uh
you know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than five
thousand dollars so what we do is we use
conditional formatting to highlight the
cells based on the criteria it's a very
useful tool in analyzing data and
Visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the data in quick flash you
will see the data and it's quite visible
using the conditional formatting so how
we do that is I will show it to you now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see who has done more sales
which is greater than the five thousand
dollars so just go to home and you need
to say go to conditional formatting so
for that you need to highlight or select
this go home conditional formatting
highlight okay and you have different
options here you select creator that and
you specify the value I here my criteria
is five thousand dollars okay we can
select which color so let's go for green
okay
see this you will immediately see the
option you don't have to dig or look in
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index function
is a very powerful tool wherein you know
you for example you have a table of
planets in our solar system and you want
to get the name of the fourth planet
Mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time you can use the match function okay
with the match function together you can
play wonders with it okay match function
is another function that is designed to
find the position of an item in a Range
example we can use the match function
to get the position of a word or look or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the index and match function to find
the city how we do that is shown here
okay it it looks quite complicated here
when you see the formula but I can show
it to you in the Excel and explain it
further okay so here I have and I want
to know where these people are and where
they belong to okay
so
let's see how it goes uh we have seen it
and we use the index function okay
index okay now when I have to specify
the range okay so the range is A2 and it
shows it selects the
name and I want to select it from A2 to
E7 okay E7 sorry
e
called E7 okay so as you see it
highlights the whole table okay now what
I'm going to do is I want to match it
okay match it with a condition I am I am
specifying a condition a 10 why because
I have to specify a name here and it
will show me the city where he belongs
to okay where it shows is a
two okay if you see A2 it shows the name
through A7 I have to specify the range
here okay not just one name we are
specifying the holding as you see if you
put the values it will show you the
selection
okay as soon and what it should be it
should be the exact match so 0 denotes
the exact match parenthesis is closed
and I am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output what output is okay
B9 okay this is my city D9 is the city
where I'm trying to find from okay and
what it should look for is a column A A1
through
e one okay let's select these this
particular row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay let's see how it goes
if we give you an error because you
haven't put the value here okay so let's
see
thank you
Andrew okay hit enter and you will see
the city where he belongs to okay
now let's see where Anna belongs
hit enter let's choose Dallas okay so
this is the one other function index and
match function being used and it can be
asked in frequently in the interview
questions okay the next question will be
uh how to find duplicate values in a
column okay there are two ways that you
can actually do this and one is
basically the very simple one which is
the conditional formatting and the other
one is we have seen this before count if
function okay how we do that you need to
Simply select the data and go to
conditional formatting and select
duplicate values and it's quite simple
and there is another way which give you
the color coded conditional formatting
okay there is another way that is the
countif function how we do that is again
the you have to put another column and
put up a counter criteria contact
function wherein you see that you are
specifying the range
and the the value which is being twice
or enter duplicate and you have to put
up a condition I'll show it to you in
the text so here we have the data and I
need to find the duplicate values here
so I just select this and as I said it's
quite simple go to conditional
formatting form and then go to
conditional formatting and select
highlight cell rules and simply go down
and select the duplicate values okay it
will give you which color you want you
can simply select red R anything as you
see the moment you select you will see
the duplicate values highlighted okay so
I just cancel this and there is another
way then count a function so I'll put
another column where it says duplicate
names and I will put up a count tab
function here
okay so let's see how a counter function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate names so as I said I will put
up a formula a function here for the
count f
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
count it and uh since it's an absolute
reference I have to put up a dollar
symbol
okay my reference here will be H the
column here h
2
okay
then again dollar is I'm using it as an
absolute reference
colon
through
dollar symbol again
nine okay so it drags still at the whole
it drags till the
all the names okay the H9 all right and
then
what I'll do is I'll put a comma in y I
want to do is I have to select H2
okay this is my criteria I mean it is
repeating twice all right
and
I have to close the parenthesis and if
it is more than one okay so this is my
formula I just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition and it is true okay I simply
drag it the whole thing and whether
events is uh repeated yes it's true
Andrew it's a duplicate entry false me
is a duplicate entry and it says true
and as you see me and events are
duplicate entries so this is how we use
the counter function and the conditional
formatting to sort duplicate entries in
the date
now let's move on to the last question
for The Beginner's level and since we
have duplicate entry there is also a
problem to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to Simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values select it and
delete it okay and this is one tedious
way of doing it and you can also after
deleting the values you can go to the
conditional formatting choose clear
rules to remove the rules from the sheet
so this is one way okay the next thing
is again a simple button that is there
in the data tab that is the
is one of the tools present in the data
which is simply called as remove
duplicates it's quite simple and it's
there in the data tools let me show you
in the Excel so here we are and we have
this data and we need to check and
remove the duplicate so as I said go to
the data Tab and simply click on remove
duplicates and when you click on it it
will ask you you want to continue or
expand this selection I just say
continue with the current selection and
to move duplicates okay select all click
ok to duplicate entries that were
removed previously we saw that events
and
[Music]
and over there any weather so that has
been removed okay
so that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300 in
demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like a higher
level or intermediate level compared to
the previous things that we have
discussed with the basic level questions
for the Excel interview so let's move on
to the next thing
and so there are there are some
scenarios where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet and
you need to find out what is the day of
the week okay so you might be asked your
question how do you find out the day of
a week for a particular date so that is
the function we we have a specific
function and that is the weekday
function to find out the day of the week
for a particular date okay so as we know
these are the seven days of the week and
we just put the function as it says
equals to V K and we need to enter the
column or the area or the cell address
here so weekday is the function and it
will give you the
which which day it is of the V okay we
go as it says one it denotes something
okay and three is again Tuesday okay so
this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
Excel so basically Excel scores three
types of wild card which are
Asterix the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next Wild Card is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single characters okay whereas Asterix
is it represents any number of
characters and the third one which is
really used in Excel it is the tilde it
is used to identify a wild card
character that is till the Asterix
question marks in the text okay and it
is very rarely used so you need to
memorize these three things that the
there are three types of wild cards we
can see the functions of this in the
later sessions okay the X1 is we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data values what is
what is it used for and you you should
know how to set up in an example okay
data validation is a feature in Excel
that is used to control what a user can
enter into a cell okay so you have with
the data validation you are not allowing
a data kind of data that should be input
in the cell okay for example you have
the authority by setting up the data
validation that you can enter either a
number or a text or a just a number and
so on okay using the data validation and
where is it available it is in the data
tab okay select data validation option
present under data tools okay and you
just need to select the particular cells
where you want to set up the data
validation I'll show it to you in an
example so this is how it looks like you
just need to go to data tools and click
on data validation and it will show you
and you have the options here allow and
if you click on the drop down you will
see different options like I will show
it to you in the example here okay
for this particular thing if I want you
know this column should have only names
and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay so there are some columns where you
have to put only names or you have to
put only number so you can set this up
with the data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up another so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell okay so here as an example I have
some data where I am putting the names
here and I'll put the salary here I want
to make sure that you know we cannot
enter any numbers here okay it should be
only text it should have only name so
how do I perform that how do I restrict
any user to
that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation and here in the
setting I'll go to custom there are
different options here you can you can
choose whole numbers decimal list date
time so your these are the option and I
go to custom and I am giving a
particular formula here okay what is
that it should be only text okay so it's
a simple thing it should be text and I
need to define the range okay so how
I'll Define the ring I just select this
okay and
right select the range okay
so I have selected the range here and if
you go to input message
and error alert you can customize it and
here we are taking the default one and
this is the input message if you want to
set or customize something okay so let's
see how it works okay I have said this
and then I try to put a number here and
it throws me an error the value entered
is not variant because we have set a
restriction a user has restricted value
that can be entered into the cell so
this is how the data validation work
okay the next thing is you will be given
a situation wherein you have to you will
be given data and you have to punch
perform a function like in this example
we are taking a condition wherein you
will have data and you have to specify
the result based on the data you have to
formulate it okay so given below is a
student table write a function to add
password fail to the results column
based on the the following criteria you
will be given a criteria so this is the
student table you are giving the student
names marks and attendance and then
based on that you will have to specify a
next uh a formula wherein you will see
the result okay based on the past
student data you have to put a pass fail
results in the column based on the
following criteria what is the criteria
and for example here in this example
what they're saying is you have to say
that the student is passed if his marks
is more than 60 and the attendance is
more than 75 percent okay so how we
perform this function as it says you
have to use the IF function and check
with the hand condition to fill the
results column okay so let's see this in
the example here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
IF function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so I have to put the IF function here
okay and check with the and function
okay and I have to specify the
conditions I have to subscribe where it
should see the or check the conditions
okay so we are checking the conditions
here and the marks should be in row um
in the column U and it starts with u5 so
let's see U 5 okay it will immediately
go to column U and 5 row five okay and
then what is the condition we are
satisfying here it should be greater
than 60 okay and the other condition is
uh the column V that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying V 5 should be greater
than
75 okay
and we just close this conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
[Music]
pass
comma in quotes again
three okay so let's see how this works
okay
foreign
Ty so he is failed because he has marks
are 50 his attendance must be more than
75 but yes he is he has not scored marks
more than 60. so we drag the same
formula to the whole thing and you will
see the result okay this is quite simple
and you will see this
e formula and using the if and
check and check with and condition okay
now moving on to the next question you
might be asked to you know this is a
simple function wherein you can you will
be asked to calculate your age in years
from the current date okay so how we do
that there is a particular function and
it's very simple use the ear flat or
dated IF function to return the number
of whole days between start date and the
ended so you specify a start date which
will be uh today's date and the I mean
the birthday and then the end day will
be today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the age using the ear
Frac function and dated F function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the ear Frac function okay
you specify this function and then
specify the inputs that is the today's
date and the date of birth and the
today's date okay and this is one of the
ways to get it and there is also gated F
okay this again it is dated a function
and you specify the input cells okay so
let me show you an example for the same
so here we are and we have today's date
that is 4th of May and date of birth for
anything it could be so I will specify
the EF right okay equals
here rack okay
and then I should as soon as he enters
you specify the start date and the end
date okay and I will specify the start
date as today's date let's fix the
column and then I put the comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay and just close it and it will
give you the
each
okay so this is the eight for example if
you want to find out my age I don't want
to reveal my birthday but it's okay
um
okay
let's see if it calculates
I'm 32 years old okay all right so this
is one of the ways and similarly you can
use the dated function shown in the
example all right now moving on to the
next question you have nested if
statements this is very important and
you will definitely be coming across
this question how are nested if
statements used in Excel what are nested
if statements the F function can be
nested I mean it can be Loop when we
have multiple conditions to meet okay it
can be nested the false value is
replaced by another IF function okay you
have specified some condition and you
are uh putting up a condition and if
that condition is not there or not met
then if it will be replaced with another
IF function so the syntax will be like
this below is an example so we actually
we use two if statements in conjunction
okay so here is an example here we are
specifying a condition wherein you know
uh the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 16 it is
bad or average so this is very simple
you are perform one if condition and if
that is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements okay uh I'll
show the same example here in the Excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their Mars okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is less
than 60 it is bad or average okay so how
we get this is we use two if conditions
if
statements so as we've seen it if
now the first condition is our source or
the source is B2 okay so B
2
and what I am specifying is it should be
greater than
80. all right I just close this and the
result should be excellent okay
foreign
excellent if it is more than 80 and if
this condition is not met it will go to
the next if statement okay we are
nesting another if statement what is the
condition here for the next statement it
will check D2 is
less than or equal to 60 you can specify
any marks all right so if it is less
than 60 it should give the result as bad
or average okay
specify anything and you
okay
and just close the double parenthesis so
let's see how it works okay see it works
like this
now let's pull up the same formula the
for the other results okay
see if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay and now in this case for
Mark it is bad why because it will first
see whether it's excellent or not if it
is not excellent then it will check the
other condition if it is less than 60 it
will give you the have a bad result all
right and similarly so on for the other
months all right so this is how we use
the nested if statements you are adding
two if statement the first condition and
the second condition with another if
statement okay okay when it comes to
excel it is basically involves a lot of
data and a lot of data to be analyzed
and we have some powerful tools which
are used in Excel to analyze the data
one such uh important tool is
descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so we
might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis too
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics option in Excel for the data
analysis okay how you do that is you
have to add a pack okay you should be
knowing that you need to add a pack
which is called the analysis tool pack
which you go to file options and then
just click on the add-on and select the
analysis tool pack click Excel add-in
and just click go and it will add the
option and then when you select the data
you have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be which will
show up when you select the Addle or
when you add the Addam okay then you
need to select the descriptive
statistics what we need to do is we need
to analyze this data and it will show
you the values like mean and the you can
also customize you can you see you have
this data and for you to check each and
every row and find the mean the smallest
the
maximum number and things like that so
this can be easily done using the
descriptive statistics for the data
analysis uh I'll show the same thing in
the Excel how it can be performed so
here we are and I'll show you first how
to add the
option to it okay go to add and select
analysis tool pack as shown in the slide
and you need to click go if you just
click OK it will not add so just click
go and then you need to select analysis
tool pack okay it will give you these
are the different options uh for now we
are selecting analysis tool pack and
let's click OK as soon as you do that
you will see the data analysis this
option gets enabled when you add that
pack so this is the data that you have
you need to find or analyze using the
descriptive statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there and if
you want me to show I will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
date
okay this is my input range you need to
select this labels in the first row so
that you know it doesn't take the first
row okay I'll show
foreign
you are getting a summary statistics
which is the default and you can select
the confidence level that is the mean
value and you can set it up by whatever
value percentage you want and you are
selecting the largest one and the
smallest number so all these data will
get analyzed and it will open up in a
new sheet and just click OK and you will
see this so these are the if you see
this is our data paid organic social and
revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more precise
okay so with a single click yeah all our
data is analyzed okay this is the mean
value and this is the minimum is zero
maximum is so you can set this is the
total and the number of count is
thousand so you don't need to scroll
down and check what is the largest
amount that is paid so this is the
largest amount for the
wait okay and so on so before the
largest revenue generated all these
things are generated with a descriptive
analysis okay descriptive statistics
with the data analysis too so the next
question is about a pivot table and this
is more refined or more advanced
compared to the last one that we
discussed in the beginner level so here
you are asked to create a pivot table to
find the total cases in each country
belonging to their respective continents
you are giving you are being asked to
put up a table or pivot table with two
variables basically each country and
their respective continent so again we
have the same data and we need to set up
a pivot table which shows the continents
and the countries with the respective
continuous the number of cases okay so
let's see how we get this in the example
so here we are we have the same data it
shows the days months your cases
countries
and there
are consonants okay
continents here and so on okay so I am
I'll go to the insert Tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing I
will be asked to enter the input range
okay so I select this
and since it's huge I'll just
put the number to be seven seven seven
okay let's assume
now this is our input data and where you
want the output to be it's already
selected you can put it anywhere I am
putting it here okay just click OK and
it will give you the option to select
the fields now what we want is number of
cases okay which will show you the value
and the countries and territories there
respective continents so okay so this is
how it looks like and we have to check
now it is asking us to find the
countries Okay so
with their respective continents you see
this you see Africa as a continent and
you will see
okay
you will see Africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of on I mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries territories with
their respective continents you will see
as such if you just expand this we will
see the countries that are having the
cases in the continent Africa okay so
country wise sorted with the continents
okay this is the other Advanced step to
get the data or show the data in the
pivot table okay another question that
you might be asked this is a basic and
we have already seen this in the
previous example that I have shown how
do you provide the dynamic range in data
source of a pivot table you have to
select a particular data source in your
input table for to show up in the pivot
table so you have to select the input
range but how do you create or how do
you create or provide a dynamic range in
this data switch so just need to create
a name table to provide a dynamic range
so where is the data of your table so as
we have seen in the previous example you
will be able to select the input range
and you just need to put this value any
number so that you know it will pick up
the dynamic range for your input source
for the tape okay so now we move on to
the next one and this is about about the
pivot table again is it possible to
create pivot table using multiple
sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheets
can you create a pivot table for all the
worksheet in a single pivot table yes
you can but there is a condition there
should be a common Row in both the table
so you cannot have different types of
data there should be a common row okay
so then only it will act as a primary
key for the first table and the
quarantee for the second table okay so
this is something that you have to
remember and you need to create a
relationship between the tables and then
build the pivot table so you have to
analyze what kind of data it is it
should have a common Row in both the
tables on both the sheets and then you
have to establish a relationship between
this table and then build the table okay
there is a visit for that well
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you I will be asked to further
refine or you know refine your search
and show it in the data so here we have
with the code data example again you
will be asked to create a pivot table to
find the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the coveted again and we have done this
before we have created a preview table
for this and we need to further refine
it showing the top three countries with
the number of cases and I will show that
same thing in the Excel and we already
have created a table and we'll refine it
further to show the top three countries
which are having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the table uh already with us and I
just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so you just need to go here and you need
to select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and now I select top 10 and what I
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these things okay
and based on the sum of cases okay this
is our field already then just click OK
and it will show you the top three
countries so it's quite simple and it is
very important to know this field and
how you play with the value of the
filters for each particular field in the
pivot table so it shows you these things
all right and now you can refine it
further with the continents and all okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right we
have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay like you will be given a
situation where you need to add one more
column and show it in the pivot table
with a particular calculation or with
the particular value and you have you
don't have that actual value in your
data but you have to calculate it and
show it across in the table so there is
another option which is called pivot
table analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option so when you go to your
table and then go to pivot table analyze
you will see the option to add a
calculated field okay just go there and
click select calculated field and you
need to Define so in this example we are
going to Define another column where we
calculate the bonus of the sales and
there is a particular Formula E formula
is you put an if and statement and then
you calculate the formula you specify
what is the bonus and what is the way
that you're calculating the bonus and it
will particularly add it another column
to your table so let's see how we do
that in the
table act so here we are we have this
table and I have inserted a pivot table
and I am putting it in
output here
okay
and then you will get the table okay now
you need to select the
customer name
and the unit sold unit price sales okay
so we'll add another column to it how we
do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay you
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus
foreign
[Music]
statement which we have seen before how
we uh put up a
an event statement okay now I'm going to
say it has
[Music]
like this sales my sales should be
I'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and the unit sold okay I am trying to
put it as the unit sword which also
depends on the units sold
is greater than thousand okay for
example let's say a thousand a person
who is uh
able to do uh sales of 4000 and the unit
sold should be more than thousand then
the sales
what is this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus and sales
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus click add
okay so we have added this and we have
put up a calculation for the formula and
you will see this in the so this is
simple way of adding the column to your
existing data and we are doing the
calculations and showing it up okay so
this is one way go to pivot table
analyze and field items and sets you can
select this option and add it okay you
can customize this as I said with adding
different fields this is pretty handy in
analyzing the data which does not exist
in the table and you add some value to
your pivot table okay
the next question will be about slicer
you must be familiar with what a slicer
is in a pivot table and how do you use
it for the purpose of using it and how
do you put up a slider in the pivot
table so how does a slicer work
basically slicers are used to further
filter data in the pivot table suppose
you already have some data and it's for
ease that you can do it by just adding a
slicer you can select particular uh
data in or a field and you can see the
output for that particular field that
you have chosen in the slicer okay so
it's very simple go to the insert Tab
and select slicer under printers okay
and then it will be like this okay and
here if for example you see this is our
period table we have added two slicers
to filter our table that is month and
countries and territory so this will be
the general pivot table that looks like
and we haven't added another two slices
that is month and Country so if you go
for example if you want to see what is
the number of cases and some of the
deaths for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see and do this in our Excel okay
so there is a table or pivot table
already created for this and I want to
add a slicer so how do I go ahead and do
this is I go to the
options and insert slicer okay at the
moment you click on it you will see what
are the options that you want to add you
can select different fields and
select the slicer product uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the and again
this will be our slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
territories okay
click on that and you will see two
simple badges here that you can choose
from so if I want to know in the month
of Feb how many number of cases were
there per particular let's see the
moment I choose the month it will show
that particular number of the
corresponding table for the whole and
now I want to further refine it to a
particular country so for example
Australia okay so there were total
number of 18 cases and zero deaths at
the same time if I go for Algeria it is
like this so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
Manner and ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country in
continues to the turkey cases again the
same example for our code the kovid one
in this time we want to show the output
as the percentage of contribution for
each country and continents to the total
cases so we have the same data and we
generate a pivot table and we should
show it as the sum of the cases to be
percentage okay and this is how we do it
this is our
data and I'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table and here I have to
show what is the fields that we need to
select okay first is we are just
selecting the cases and the countries
and territories Okay so
cases to be the values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when I see
[Music]
that it shows the number of cases now if
I just want to refine it further and see
it as number of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how I do it show field
list I go here and I go to Value field
settings okay then
again
number format show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing
percentage of grand total and then just
click okay
and you will see
this to be the percentage so it shows
the data in the form of percentage okay
this is very simple and you just need to
remember as we have seen before
super field and then value field
settings okay this is the thing that you
need to check okay Grant percentage
there are other options also and you can
select from whatever you want to create
in this case we are showing it to be the
percentage okay okay guys now the next
question is about a very important
aspect a presentation when we come to
private charts how do you create a
favorite chart in pivot tables this is
very
basic or very you know important aspect
of pivot tables that you can represent
data in a in a form of a chart and there
are different types of charts which I'll
show it to you in the uh example okay so
we have a data here and we want to show
it at in and right now it is in a
tabular form okay we have put up a pivot
table for this and now if the same thing
can be put up in a pivot chart okay so
what you need to do is go to the insert
Tab and select the pivot chart it
depends on different versions of excel
that you have different uh forms or
different buttons so I will show it
across to you and this is how it looks
like okay it's very simple it can be a
pie chart it can be a bar chart it can
be different forms and we can see that
in the example here okay so let's go to
the example and
so we have the pivot tables generated
here already what you need to do is you
need to select the table and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is Pi Bar area scattered and other parts
okay there are different forms okay so
right now what we do is we will select
the column chart here okay you need to
select the pivot table and click on the
column chart again there are different
forms which can be seen in some time now
so this is the basic form okay and it
will show you the countries I mean the
and it will show it as a form of a chart
okay again you can change the chart type
you can change it to Pi okay this
personally is very good in presenting or
doing presentation and you can select
different forms different styles okay
I'll also show you the percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table into a chart okay again bar type
is also there
so this won't suit here in our example
there are different parts I'm just
showing it to you as how it looks like
so depending on your uh I mean the
aesthetic you can see and select what
kind of chart is best suitable okay
so this is how you put up a pivot chart
in pivot tables okay
so this is when last for the
intermediate level and uh what are
macros in Excel create a macro to
automate a task basically you have some
daily tasks that you perform in Excel
okay and you can do this with quite ease
using the macros okay it basically is a
program that resides within the Excel
file and it is used to automate tasks in
Excel some daily tasks that you run like
run when you come across in any data and
you have to scrub that data and you do
some daily routines and by removing some
columns or adding some formulas and you
know doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a macro and this is what
macro is used for in Excel so how you
capture those steps in Excel is through
a macro to record a macro you can either
go to the developer tab in the Excel and
click on record macro or you can use or
access it from The View tab Okay so
these are the
ways to access macros okay just go to
the developer tab and click record macro
wherein you know when you click record
macro it will record the steps that you
are performing in each step and it will
capture that and you can save that it is
like a daily routine that you run and
you can do all these multiple steps
maybe n number of steps within a single
click by running that macro later on
okay so you record a macro and run that
okay you do it through the developer tab
go to developer tab and click record
macro and it records all the steps that
you are performing okay you need to name
it and you just need to perform the
actions and it will record the macro and
you just save it later on whenever you
come across to the same daily task that
you run you can just click it by running
that macro okay
wow so in a single click it will perform
all the actions that you have done or
steps that you have performed on that
particular Excel sheet or any other
Excel sheet okay this is very handy when
you have similar data and you do the
similar task each day okay so this ends
the intermediate level and in the next
slides we will see the advanced level so
now we discuss the advanced level uh
interview questions for Excel and when
it comes to the advanced level you will
come across definitely you will be asked
about what if analysis how does it work
how does it how does what-if analysis
work in Excel so what if analysis as the
name suggests you have to have
an analysis done okay with the help of
different complex mathematical
calculations like formulas and using
different formulas and calculations you
can experiment with the data and you can
analyze if this particular input changes
what will be the scenario how will your
output turn out to be so as you can see
it is about different variables to see
how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so this is what
what if analysis is and the same thing
can be done with Excel and how it is
done is you need to go to the data Tab
and click on the what if analysis under
forecast okay so there are three options
in
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the data table so these are the
three situation or three tools which are
available in the what-if analysis in the
data tab okay so goal seek is basically
for reverse calculations okay and you
have some idea you have some set goal in
mind and you have certain variables and
what you need to do and what you need to
achieve to have certain set goals okay
you have you will set a value for the
goal and with the goal seek option you
can get to know what value you have to
achieve to come to that level okay so
this is what goal seek is it is one of
the simplest sensitivity analysis tool
and so for example you know that you
know a single outcome you would like to
achieve like you have a set goal that
you have to achieve this particular
grade okay and the goal seek feature in
Excel allows you to arrive to that goal
by mathematically adjusting a single
variable within that equation so you set
the goal and you will do the what-if
analysis goal seek
option to know what you have to do or
what you have to achieve for the set
goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis okay so in this scenario
you the data tables allow the adjustment
of only one or two variables within a
data set but each variable can have
unlimited number of possible values okay
so basically they are used for side by
side comparisons
um it makes it very easy to read the
scenarios okay one but you need to set
up the data table correctly okay and
what you do is you give the input in the
table and then you set up the formula
and for instance you need to calculate
the monthly payments for a loan okay you
provide the principal amount like
whatever amount you are taking 2 lakhs
three lakhs and you set the interest
rate in a formula okay
and you set the term in and then you
need to provide different uh input
options like what loan amount that
you're taking and you set the formula
and go to data table and I mean go to
what if analysis and select the data
table table stretches across and then
you will see the monthly payment options
or the monthly Emi that you can
calculate there are different uh things
that you can calculate you can calculate
the Target or the sales bonus or things
like that okay giving different
scenarios in the variables okay but you
need to set up a data table it might be
a little challenging but yes it is a
very powerful tool okay so the next one
is the scenario manager it is a bit more
complicated compared to the other two
but then it is uh more advanced than
Google c as it allows you the uh to
adjust the multiple variables at the
same time okay and the this is very
complicated compared to the other two
and it is even I mean it gives more
better output when it Compares with the
other two what-if analysis tools
so here when you go to what if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to analyze what if you
are changing the value of your interest
amount or the
term of loan or your targets like
monthly targets or an yearly targets and
things like that and you just have to uh
see what the scenario will be when you
set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in Excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
VBA okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the task it is performing okay
so when you are writing a module you
will have a function when you have a
function it will always give you a value
okay for example you are performing an
addition it using the function it will
give you a value for sure whereas
subroutine it does not return a value of
the task it is performing functions are
called by a variable okay you can set up
a variable and you can call the function
okay whereas subroutines can be recalled
from anywhere in the program in multiple
times okay in many different ways you
can recall a subroutine like we have
seen we write a subroutine and we put up
a button and we can when you click the
button it will recall the subroutine
functions are called by variable okay
you have to set up a variable and when
you enter it it will come up okay
functions are used directly in
spreadsheet as formulas whereas Subs
cannot be used directly in spreadsheets
as formula okay this is very important
difference and the next thing is the
functions can be used to perform
repetitive tasks and return a value
whereas users must insert a value in the
desired cell before getting the result
of the sub so this is particularly
limited okay whereas functions can be
used to perform different repetitive
tasks and return a value user input is
not required whereas if you see the
subroutines user must insert a value
okay in the desired cell that way in a
particular cell which is defined in the
subroutine to getting the desired result
okay so these are the differences
between functions and subroutines now
the next one is what is the difference
between this workbook and active
workbook nvdf so when you work on
modules and different Excel spreadsheets
and workbooks you will have these
different workbooks open and there is a
particular difference and you might be
asked what is the difference between
this workbook and active workbook so as
the name suggests this workbook refers
to the name of the workbook where the
code is actually running from okay you
are running a code VBA code and it is
the actual workbook where you are
running the code from and that is this
workbook okay and you have multiple
spreadsheets open and you are working on
particular suppose for example you are
working on a sheet X okay and you active
workbook is the workbook that is
currently active from the different open
verbs you have different open workbooks
but you are working on one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
reference to the name of the Virgo where
the code is actually written whereas
active workbook is the one one that is
currently open currently active Okay so
this is the difference between this
workbook and the active workbook in vbe
as shown in the example this is a simple
sub that is written a code that can be
written to find out which workbook is
the uh it which workbook is the uh this
workbook in the VBA and the active
workbook as well okay so this is a
simple thing that you can run to
determine okay it shows the active
workbook and the this workbook okay so
as we move on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a PBF function okay
there are two ways if any arguments can
be passed to a VBA function as a value
or as a reference so this is an example
that you can see it is by reference the
key word for this is by reference okay
so when you are pressing an argument by
reference the keyword should be by ref
whereas by value you're specifying a
value and the keyword is by v a l value
okay so these are the two ways that you
can pass an argument in VBA
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
buyer that is the keyword before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the keyword that
is being used okay and by reference is
the default in the VBA and let's use
specify something else which in this
case is by value okay and as I said the
keyword for buy value passing the
argument y value is by v a l okay so
when you set the keyword by Van the
variable what happens is the by value
argument function or argument
is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here which
means it assigns a value to the variable
X here okay because the variable was
passed by value in the function any
change to the value okay any change to
the value of the variable is only the
current function so it ends after it
performs the function okay then it
revert backs to the value when it is
declared again where it is set to zero
so if the variable has been passed by
reference in the function then the
variable would have permanently assumed
the new assigned value so this is the
basic Difference by reference and by
value
so now we move on to the next one so
there might be a question that you will
be asked that how do you find the last
row or a column in your VBA okay so to
find a last row sometimes you have long
list of uh data and it has like
like a number of rows and N number of
columns so instead of scrolling down all
together to find the uh last row you can
use this VBA code you can write this
code it's a very simple one and it will
give you the last row you will find the
last row with the single click okay
let's see it in the VBA so here I have a
sheet which you know it has long list of
uh rows and instead of scrolling down I
can just find out the last row with this
VBA code okay I just click on this and
as seen in the slideshow I have just
returned it and we will create if you
just run it and you will see the number
of rows it will give you the last row in
the sheet okay similarly we can do this
for the column as well okay in case if
you have long list of our large number
of columns instead of scrolling right
you can just uh run this VBA and you can
see you can know the
the last number of column okay number of
columns so as we've seen in the last row
now we'll see the code for the finding
the last column it's the same thing uh
instead of row you will see it as column
all right and if when you run it you
will give the it will give you the last
column okay
now let's move on to the next one so you
might be asked this how do we check
whether a file exists or not in a
specified location there is a code
simple VBA code that you can write and
you can run you can use this utility to
find out whether the file exists or not
okay and you need to check whether the
file exists and if it does it will give
you a message that the selected file
exist and if it doesn't it will pop up
with the message box saying that the
file selected file doesn't exist so what
you need to do is you have to specify
this function okay and check file exist
this is what it does okay you have to
specify a variable that is the store
file name where you will give the
location the location of the file and
the name of the file okay and then you
will also specify whether the file name
is there or not now so it runs this and
it will see either the file name exists
or the file actually exist or not
and it will give the appropriate message
box we can run the same thing in my PC
and we can check it
so here we are I have put this and I
have done the same thing and what I'm
looking for is this book 2 okay let me
maximize it this is what I'm looking for
and the location is desktop okay so let
me run this and you will see whether it
exists or not okay and it says this to a
selected file exists so it goes and
checks whether the file exists and then
it will give you the message so this is
how we check using the VB so the next
one is uh you know there is a powerful
tool called debug and you need to you
might be asked questions about how debug
works or how you check the debug okay to
debug a video code line by line you can
use the f8 key okay you can also create
a breakpoint to terminate the execution
so for this if you go to your VBA you
will see the option as debug okay you
can use this
by clicking on debug or by pressing the
f8 key okay so what debug does is it
will show you the step-by-step execution
of your steps okay it will check each
and everything and if there is an error
it will pop okay and the what is
breakpoint is at some point of time you
can check one particular step okay you
can stop the if suppose if there is a
thousand line codes and you want to
check on one particular step like maybe
800 step so just go to go to that
particular step and you can enter a
breakpoint and it will show you what is
actually happening at the that point
that particular step and you can see
this in the locals window or the watch
window okay so let me show you some
simple example of how this debug can be
used to check our course okay so here I
have written a simple code for this and
it is basically let me show you how
debug works okay this is the let me
maximize it and we will see okay so this
is the debug option that you can run and
you will see what happens okay this can
be done by clicking f8 all right so step
into is the option and you can check
f8 and you can press f8 again it will go
to the next step all right and it will
show you what's happening actually uh
you can see this in a locals window
what's actually happening let me see let
me maximize it a bit
so that you can actually see okay so
when I press f8 okay
step into
you will see what happens in The Next
Step okay this is what is happening a is
empty B is 0 I is zero okay I step into
it the next step again so it goes here
you can see what changes happen I press
f8 again
so this is what is happening all right
so it is checking each and every step so
debug is the tool that you can use to
check the course whether see this is a
very simple program but then you will
have some different codes where you
functions or routines that you can have
where you have thousand line codes and
you need to check each and every step or
some particular step so this comes in
very handy okay let me press f8 and it
shows what happens in which uh you can
step into each and every step and see
what happens okay and now if I show
there is something called as toggle
breakpoint okay this one particular is
used by
pressing the F9 key wherein you will see
what is actually happening at some
particular step okay so how you do that
is you just need to go to a particular
step and click on the bar here and it
will get highlighted into red so so this
is what is happening okay so in the
watch window you will see that
particular step will be uh magnified or
you can see what is actually happening
in the step okay so let me start it
again
see what happens
I press f8 again
so here it sees it actually shows you
can toggle and you can see what is
happening in the watch window at that
particular step so module one ABC the
variant is empty so expression is B this
is what is happening at this particular
step okay so this is how debug can be
used
so now as we move on to the next one
well you might be asked to create a bar
chart with the given data using VBA so
you will have some data and you can
create a bar chart or a any kind of
chart with the VBA we have done it with
the pivot tables and all but then we can
do the same with the VBA so it's a
simple thing a simple sub that you can
drag and create embedded chart using
chart object this is the sub that you
can use okay you are specifying a
variable here and ambigital you need to
specify the embedded chart and which
sheet you are using and this is very
basic and the charge a chart objects
like the length the dimensions of the
chart okay and you need to specify the
source okay the source which sheet for
range so and so you can specify the
range here so uh let's go and do the
same thing in the Maybe
so here I have the data and let I've
already copied the VBA for it and let me
simply run it okay
see it creates a chart so this comes in
very handy and you can see the as I have
mentioned in you have to specify the
source the dimensions of the chart and
so on so and so on okay you are
specifying where it's picking up the
data from and the columns I'm in the
range and the dimensions of the chart
okay you can play with this and you will
generate a chart so
well this ends our presentations in so
this is how it looks like and we have
seen that so next question is about a
VBA code again to calculate the area of
a rectangle using the PBA function how
do you include a function to calculate
the area of a rectangle we will all know
that the area of a rectangle is length
into width okay that is the formula we
can execute it with the by defining a
function in the VBA and we'll Define the
same function function is equal to area
and it is area as length into width in
this scenario I'll again show it to you
how we do this in Excel and
let's go ahead and do this
so here we are I will just go to the
developer tab and open the vpa and I
insert a module okay so here we will
Define the function okay function
as area okay this is my function and now
I'm going to define the radicals okay
length
as
double because
we want to make sure that it takes the
decimals as well okay and wait actually
okay now what is the area
formula for example a equals to
length
into event
okay
very simple
okay now I go to my Excel and I'll
Define the area for function okay
let's take the length to be put in
A1 and the width to be put in B1 okay
now if I just put the value here
it will take 12 and my width is 36 3 and
it shows the area to be 36 okay
11
so this is the area if you just go and
Define it I mean try to enter area A1
and V1 it will not so we have to define
the function here using the VBA code
okay now let's go back to the slide and
we'll discuss this so here uh it has
been shown as a you know we have a
rectangle when the when width is not
provided so that is if the rectangle is
a square they will not be given the
width so we are defining again length as
double optional optional is we are
giving an argument that it is optional
width as a variant width as a variant
means it can be zero okay so we are
defining it as if missing width then the
area should be length into length Okay
as the area is length into wet as we
have seen okay so this is one way to
define a function for the area of a
rectangle okay let's go to the next
slide so you might be asked about a VBA
function to check if the number is prime
or not we all know what a prime number
is a prime number is divisible by 1 and
itself for example 2 3 5 7 11
13 17 and so on and these are the prime
numbers and anything which is divisible
by any other number like 8 or 4 or 16
which has a divisor is not a prime
number so we all know this and we will
write a VBA code to check if the number
is prime or not so this is the one that
is given and we will do the same in the
VBA okay before moving ahead I will just
explain these uh the code and what we
are doing here is basically we are
defining three variables okay we are
declaring three variables one integer
variable okay and we call it as divisors
all right and then the next one is the
one long variable long
as the number and I as long okay here
long specifies variables because it has
got the larger capacity than the integer
values okay the divisor will be zero we
are initializing the variable divisor
with the value of 0 okay the next thing
is we use a input box input box to get
the number from the user that is you
will input a number when you are asked
to uh for the input box okay so this is
the
so when the number is entered we want to
check whether this number is prime or
not okay so how do we check that okay as
we all know the condition for prime
number is it has only two number devices
that is one and itself so what we do is
we start a next Loop okay for I equals
to 1 to numbers all right so this is the
start of the loop we will Define the
conditions here
so now how do we actually perform the
operation of dividing we use the mod
operator okay this is one of the
important uh operator to check here the
mod operator will give you the remainder
of a division for example U have seven
or eight or mod by two is equal to 1
because 7 divided by 2 equals 3 with the
remainder of 1. okay so only if the only
if a number mod
I equals to 0 I is the advice divisor of
a number okay so in this case we want to
increment it by variable devices by one
so this is what we Define it as okay now
so here a check is performed like I
equals to 1. and then plus 1 I equals to
2 then plus 1 I equals to 3 and then
plus 4 I equals to
so as it goes on until it reaches the
number okay because for I equals to 1 to
number okay
so this is what is starting of the loop
now you have to close the loop so how we
do that is next I okay this is closing
the loop so this is what the loop does
now we are we have defined the check now
we have to define the result how what
happens if the divisor sees equals to 2
then the message box number should say
is a prime number all right otherwise it
should say message number should pop up
and say it is not a prime number so this
is how we Define it in the BBA let's go
ahead and do this
so here we are I have already set up and
this is the PBA so let's run it okay and
it will ask you this is the model 2
because I defined it as module 2. so the
message box opens up and it asks you to
enter a value now
is a prime number okay I run it again by
pressing the
free key okay
12.
is not a prime number so this is how we
have in we have coded a VBA code a
function to check whether the number is
prime or not
so this ends our presentation or uh
about the interview questions and end of
this full course on Microsoft Excel if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in the session or if
you need any of the data sets that are
used in this particular session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
foreign
[Music]